Your Honor, I request that this stream be struck off the
record and not be counted towards the leaderboard because of
sabotage.
Sabotage.
Exhibit A, my dog refused to poop.
He wouldn't poop.
Don't know what to do.
I got to walk him again in two hours.
I really don't want him to poop in the apartment, guys.
This is an outlier to the existing data.
I would have been on time if he pooped.
He actually even pooped last night, too.
I'm a little worried.
Not gonna lie.
I don't know if he's, I hope he's not constipated.
I had too many treats, I guess.
I didn't even the feet I he was fed when I got him well to
be fair they told me the dogs they told me he walked before
but I did an extra I did a late night walk before I had to
bed around like two in the morning and he still he didn't
poop so I was just like oh maybe you just didn't want to
poop you know maybe just pooped it all out before you got
came home and and then you know today I was just like
looking at it was like he just kept peeing he just he just
kept fucking peeing i don't know what to say all he did was
pee i was like poop and then he peed again but he had
nothing in his he had nothing left in the tank but he's just
like i'm just gonna do the pose and then maybe a little bit
of pee will come out and i'm like there's nothing left in
the tank but i know there is something in the other in the
poop tank though poop I was like I know there's stuff in
there I literally just fed you and then um and then uh okay
now okay let me show you guys the look he gave me when I was
like poop and I'll show you the look he gave me guys when I
told him to please poop
This is how he looked at me.
Give me a second.
He had crawf it so you can see just his face.
My perfect run.
Sabotaged by my own dog.
I was doing so well when he wasn't there.
I don't know.
There might be a correlation here.
There might be a little pattern.
hmm I'm on time when he's not here and then the day he came
back I was late to stream all right this was the look he
gave me when I looked at him and was like poop he just looks
at me like this he's like poop Pea?
Do you mean pee?
He has performance anxiety.
Oh, but he's fine with me washing and pee, I guess.
What do you want from me?
Like...
So I'm a little worried.
I got really scared because I'm like, oh no, what if he
pooped in the apartment?
Because I didn't wake up in time.
But coast is clear.
There's no poop in the apartment.
He just, I don't, he just refused.
I was like, you're a dog.
What do you mean you have like free will to just not poop?
When you see grass and your basic instincts, your animal
instincts takes over and you go, I go now like I told her
what do you mean you can just choose not to do it oh like oh
did like the dog sitter just like turn around every time you
need to go and now you're just used to it now you're like
that's just how I need to do it now like I don't know I
don't know anyway so in two hours I'm gonna have to walk him
again because I am I am a little worried that he's gonna
he's gonna poop in the apartment really don't want that to
happen guys so it's got someone gotta remind me when two
hours up so I can walk him downstairs he's got a lot of ammo
and he's not reloading anytime soon oh Oh, hi, hello,
everybody.
Hello, hello.
Anyway, to pivot off of that topic, unrelated to everything
I just said, did you guys hear about the Robot Olympics
that's going on right now?
Has anyone seen videos of the Robot Olympics?
the what yes there is a there's a robot olympics going on
right now in in china and it's actually fucking crazy like
actually sort of what i wish i won't watch this i wish this
was on tv or on streaming service i would absolutely this is
like my next watch along this is the future watch along the
robot olympics uh i'll show you guys it it's crazy because
the thing is like robots have no rights um and i hope they
never do
so uh because of that they they go like mock seven when
they're running and so they put like this mat at the end
like if you do the 100 meter dash they put a they put a mat
at the end of the 100 meter dash and they just fucking slam
into it they don't don't know nothing in that brain of
theirs.
Because they're just programmed to run, but they don't
program them to stop.
Yeah, so all they just like, but Kinga, run straight into
that mat, no care, no worry, and then they explode.
I'm like, holy fuck, damn, shit, wait, this shit's hardcore.
They literally, all they know is to run.
They never, they were never program to stop and then they
just run in and explode yeah they put a robot on the
wheelchair yeah i was like damn that's why i was like god i
wish i could do a watch a lot of this i wish this was on
streaming services i would 100 watch robot core olympics
sorry robot sorry my intrusive thoughts came through uh the
robot i mean i would totally watch the robot olympics and
that's no other ulterior reasons
sorry what um anyway oh yeah there was there was one where
so like you can see all these like big ass robots apparently
someone sent in a baby robot i don't know if i let me see if
i uh i don't shit this one Oh yeah, there was robot MMA
included in here.
Oh, and then there's this one.
I'm sorry.
Like, this is the tweet.
That's me in the tweet.
This tweet.
I'm starting to see the appeal of an Olympics where the
athletes just explodes and die.
I get it.
I fucking get it.
I just want to say.
I just want to see them explode.
I'm like, whoa!
That's really neat.
Also, speaking of robot news, apparently there's...
Apparently, there is also...
They live for one purpose.
Run or die!
You gotta live to run.
And have I stopped running?
I die.
All right, so speaking of robot news, also another world
update to catch you up on the current news, current world
news.
They're trying to teach robots how to fuck.
Now you're like, what do you mean by that, Doki?
they're motion capturing sex positions and and trying to
program that to robots so here's a little preview of i want
to know how much this guy's getting paid not gonna lie i
would i will say like you know how like in video game cut
scenes every like things that like you know in 3d video and
cut scenes things are all motion captured and stuff it must
be so awkward to like do like virtual motion it must be so
awkward to motion capture sex for a video game because
you're all like fully clothed in the tight uh body suit with
with uh like little motion capture balls on you and you're
pretending to you're pretending to bang with the other
person for the video game cutscene and just one must be so
fucking awkward because at least in like if you're for
movies and stuff it's also very awkward movies for those who
don't know for like in movies when you do like filming sex
scenes or whatever there's like 20 cameras all around you
and obviously the film crew is there watching as well And
so, like, you know, like, and then they have to do, like,
various takes of it.
Like, that's awkward, too.
But at least you're, like, immersed in a way, like, dressed
for the moment.
But I feel like in virtual motion capture, it's, like,
you're wearing your little, like, body suit with, like,
hundreds of balls on you.
And the little, also the shoes, too.
Like, like, yeah.
But I feel like that's much more awkward than filming a sex
scene.
N7, thank you, thank you.
Reminds me, dookitty, terms of service, terms of service,
doerobot.
Rule number one, I must run or I die.
Rule number two, when the run ends, I catch on fire and die.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Many, thank you, but super chat, thank you, thank you.
for a prototype.
NSD, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That robot was JFK.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So, so just a little current events for those who missed out
on what's going on in the robot community.
I will say the robot MMA fighting robots is also pretty,
that was pretty cool to see clips of.
But yeah.
dad doesn't recognize the leaderboards he is like you go on
my terms fuck the leaderboards i refuse to poop like please
please dad please i was so close i was so close to being
rank one minus 20 rp Minus 20 SR because of dad.
Now it's going to take me five more streams to catch up
again.
Don't you just hate it when you're one game off of rank one?
And then I have a fucking thrower on my team.
I have what?
This is a team and it's a team game.
So I have this one guy.
who decides to throw my game even though I was one game off
of rank one and now I lose 27 SR so I'll need five more
games to get back to where I need to be and he decides to
just lock the fourth DPS instead of playing for the team ah
If you can shut the fuck up You know that's not true in a
team game He made it a 5v6 instead of 6v6 He thought he was
playing Overwatch again
Please guys please play goats I'm one game off of rank 1
guys please I love that about him How the fuck you match
candidates eagle hell in real life it's a lie there's no
such thing as carrying a thrower that's a lie that's a
propaganda from throwers everywhere all right anyway playing
armor core today um i tried playing deadlock yesterday um
did not go so well i lost every game uh i wanted to learn i
will say i did enjoy playing rem i I was trying to learn
Rem.
I played one game of Rem because apparently everyone wants
to play Rem.
He's so easy.
I would say Rem is...
Rem is really...
That's when I...
Okay, you know, like, you can't care if I was that...
I was the thrower on my team.
Why did my team carry me?
Huh?
Why did I lose every game?
I'm here to...
I'm here to disprove that theory.
team didn't carry me.
Anyway, I played Deadlock before but that was like early,
early season but like I tried to play Deadlock yesterday
because I really wanted to learn Rem because I feel like
that's the only reason I would want to play Deadlock was
just to play Rem because he's just like, he's just a little
guy.
He's just a little chud, you know?
just a little chuddy guy you know um so i was like yeah a
little chuddling yeah exactly um and um at first i was like
wait a minute i'm having a great time what the fuck is okay
sorry new video dropped the robot olympics guy wait give me
a sec wait new new video has dropped on the robot hot off
hot off the press okay that's a good video that's a really
good video hot off the press the robot i demand a watch i
demand i demand this to be streamed so i can have a watch a
lot of of the robot Olympics anyway what was I saying so I
played one I played I think I played three games of deadlock
one of which I get to if I actually play rem and I was not
enjoying I was playing seven at first because everyone else
on my team is picking uh picked rem so then i was so i was
like i will stop when i get rem like that was my entire
mission i will stop when i can play rem and and so so i
finally got rem and i was like yay rem and i was having a
great time on rem like my first time playing i was like wait
this is so easy uh this is actually pretty easy and like
wait he's actually pretty fun too uh seven and ramp track
why tragic why why is it tragic seven was the last i i
someone was the last character i played before i'd stop
playing deadlock and i all i used the only one i sort of
remembered how to play to be fair i i sort of remembered how
to play him um Anyway, I was having so much fun.
I was like, oh my God.
And then I realized, and then I found out the hard way how
other players love hating Rem.
I found out the hard way how other players love to kill Rem.
Because on the midway point, I noticed that I kept dying.
And like, I know not just dying, But I noticed this haze
kept chasing me around and, uh, and like would go invisible
just to find me and just to kill me.
I was like, huh, it's a little weird that I keep dying to
this one player.
That I realized how much people love the hard focus and
abuse the child.
and so yeah no i was literally at one point i was like
heading back to my spawn and i was literally on my side of
the of the map and then this rat this haze just showed up on
my side of the map like invisible by the way he was running
i bet he was running invisible trying to find me and then
threw a sleep dart at me while i was like on the zip line on
my side of the spawn to buy upgrades and then obviously my
entire team was not with me because i was like i'm gonna go
buy upgrades and i'm like okay and then they went to like
they went push a lane and i'm like and then so halted me and
i was just like what i i eight of my deaths was just from
the haze yeah and then i got so halted by him like four
fucking times and i was just like oh i was like i can't I'm
not streaming, but he has to be stream sniping.
There's no fuck.
I'm not streaming, but I don't know.
He's hacked my disk.
He's hacked my PC.
And then he's like watching it from his monitor or
something.
He's like, he gained control of my, of my monitor somehow.
He's like watching from the window.
I have no windows, by the way.
I don't know.
He's doing something.
Something illegal.
Venmo.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We love that lot.
These players are under criminal investigation.
Thank you.
This is why you don't leave your chuddling unsupervised.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The thing is, if I'm not like holding another player's hand,
like just side by side, standing next to them i just die
like that's the only thing i don't like about rem i was like
the moment i'm like this child left in the supermarket like
alone like i passed i just follow i just kill over and like
heart attack whoa i'm dead if my hand's not holding yours
heart attack i'm dead like surprise thank you for the super
chat yeah it's like lost child simulator i just actually
just just fall on the ground in one second like i need
someone to like just hold me up or i'm making one guy in
particular absolutely miserable on purpose and then i had
the there was there's the audacity of someone on my team
that was like oh rm keeps splitting i was like No, bitch,
like, I'm sorry.
What are you?
A REM keeps splitting up.
I'm like, what?
I am, I am five centimeters away from you.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I should have been, like, right next to, I'm sorry.
I guess splitting up means the REM player is just five,
like, one foot step away.
A REM's gone.
Like, like, what do you mean?
Like, I'm sorry.
I guess that's what splitting up means now.
Yeah,
and so, guys, I don't know.
I don't know about Deadlock, guys.
The only character I actually enjoyed is, like, the most
bullied character in Deadlock.
It's the, it's the character that everybody just wants the
fucking pummel to the ground.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Deadlock on stream one.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It was like the one time I played Rem and I got the full Rem
experience.
Yeah, if I'm not directly in view, equals, wow, why is our
Rem split up all the time?
and getting picked.
I was like, what do you mean?
When you left me, I was right behind you.
You just didn't turn around.
You didn't turn around.
You kept walking forward.
All right.
Anyway, let's play armor core.
That was my life update.
I should have kept up.
I didn't realize if I don't hold your hand, I just get a
heart attack and just fucking dies.
Like those robots who live to run.
Vera, thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
I hope you had a great stream.
We are about to play some armored core.
Papa, I just gave you, I just finished giving a life update
to my, to my chat.
All right, let me look at the sound setting.
Make sure the sound settings are okay.
Armored Core, 7.3.
There you go.
All right, we're good to go.
Moonbot is not taking any sponsors today.
I need to worry about my dog pooping first Goomba has more
important things to worry about Saint, thank you for the
super chat, thank you, thank you It's 6 a.m.
morning, Doki sounding guide Reporting for duty Thank you
for the super chat, Saint, thank you, thank you Alright,
let's see I don't remember where I left off, honestly Oh
yeah, underground exploration, depths all right here we go
we're just gonna show oh wait did i do the oh wait no arena
time we're at we got some more more money i'm saving for the
next armor core update yeah i had a new arena
integration program initiating phase three so is this guy
that's hard this one's hard like he's just so fast But is he
fast enough for- Oh, that's my sword.
But is he fast enough for this?
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, guys, he might be
fast enough for this.
He might-
Possibly.
Oh, Shepherd, guys, still have the needle.
I'm lacking my big boom.
50%.
No, that's not...
No!
Not fair, my one weakness!
Speed!
Alright, there you go.
There you go.
It's okay.
Speed cannon run big booms in the end.
In the end, boom prevails.
It is moving.
Yeah, but I could have a bigger boom though you can always
go bigger you can always go bigger
all right what two more big booms yeah i feel like which
where's the oh there it is back to songbird fuck a songbird
i'm so launcher where's the bird
nut oh there it is songbird all right go big or go home
exactly exactly oh my I still can't believe it if I don't if
I stop holding your hand it just ceased to exist I'm still
thinking about oh my god it looks like a fucking bug looks
like an alien from alien franchise
is jokie good enough to beat the magoon bots this only no
weapons probably not but feel free to prove me right thank
you thank you thank you what that haze did to me they
succeeded like their their purpose oh my god wait he's so oh
my god it's a fly but it's okay god damn it
It's fine.
He's still a little fly.
Little Tim- he's still a little Timmy.
Okay, I just need him.
Oh my god!
It's fine, he's still a little Timmy.
Oh my god, no little Timmy's fighting back.
Little Timmy's having his own little fucking character arc
right now.
Yeah!
Go back to training, little Timmy's still not your time yet.
You're still not the main character yet, Lil Timmy.
Wait for five more spin-off series before it's your turn,
Lil Timmy.
I'm still the main guy here.
But that one player who totally focused on me, he succeeded.
He still, he wanted him, he wanted me to have him live
rent-free in my head, and he got it.
I think I remember the last guy is the easiest one
Integration program phase three this will be the final round
of analysis He succeeded his one and only mission Main
system activating combat mode Great That's fine This guy was
the I remember this guy.
Ah shit Oh, fuck, okay, I'm- Whoa, whoa, whoa!
I didn't mean it when I said that!
Oh!
He took that first and the least.
My bro's choking!
I- I'm slashed JK!
I'm slashed- Oh my god, he can bunker me, but he fights
back?
Main system, activating I thought we cool, bro.
I thought it...
Bro, I thought...
I thought we just...
Doing...
It's just a simulation, bro.
Bro.
I thought we cool.
There we go.
We were not cool.
That's right.
Get bunkered back.
So you guys, I told you this was the easiest one.
sorry i i like passed out for like five seconds earlier so i
didn't see what was going on yeah i know i did that this
concludes all rounds of analysis we will assimilate the
first try first try as always all right nice i have all this
money my camera really have anywhere to spend it on.
Just put it in my offshore bank accounts and gather
interest.
Incoming calls.
Thank you for your continued support.
Alright, while all mine's talking, I'm gonna get water real
quick.
This concludes the integration program's role.
The day will come when all mine's evolution truly takes
form.
Alright.
On the back.
Papa, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Oh, wait, what did she say?
Wait, what did she say?
I thought she would just say the usual thing.
I just, I thought she would just say, like, good job, Doke.
And thank you, thank you all, man.
I know I did a good job.
The one time I had to, the one time I didn't fucking hear,
listen to her.
I can't believe the one time I decided to get water.
Here's the job, 621.
To that underground facility.
Alright.
I've done this before.
I've managed to talk Archibus into letting us lead their
survey.
They jumped at the chance to use an independent mercenary as
their canary.
Balem has already barged in.
Taking several red guns and MT squads.
Seems they want to be ready for a run-in with Archibus' new
firepower.
Thank you, Joki, for teaching me how to replace you.
As if anyone can replace my big booms.
I don't even know what I'm doing.
You think an AI can predict that?
If I don't know what I'm doing, no AI is gonna figure it
out.
Yeah, what pattern?
Might as well just use a randomizer exactly.
What fucking pattern is there?
It's like a pattern?
That's news to me.
Yeah!
We're gonna meet the family again!
Where I didn't kill her entire family lineage.
Yippee!
She doesn't know that though.
She doesn't know that.
I'm restarting.
I'm hitting a restart button.
Reload.
Time where I didn't commit mass murder.
Okay, I just respawned.
The alternate universe where my wife loves me.
It's not sad.
Oh, shit.
It's this one.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, wait, I remember this.
Don't get hit.
Yeah.
the coral wait someone said it was a super easy wait let me
i bet i know what it is okay let me run i don't know when
the missile start going so
all right here i'll go
oh whoops oh this is bad for me What happened to me?
She's home.
Hello, elevator.
Elevator down.
Not kill everything.
Elevator, no go down.
I guess I go down now.
Okay.
Oh, elevator, not elevating.
What do?
Wait, guys.
Watch this.
Guys, guys, guys.
Stop watching.
Stop watching, guys.
Guys,
I did it.
That's definitely what I meant to do.
What the fuck?
There we go.
Look at that.
It's just that easy.
Stand by for now.
6-2-1.
Over there.
flag
Checkpoint one Oops wait did i not pick this up i remember
picking this up last time Well, I guess they restocked it
Yeah, it's that easy Yeah All right, watch this guys
Watch this pure skill happening.
Right now.
Okay, not now.
Not yet.
Watch this pure skill.
It's changed its combat routine, Raven.
Right?
Okay, not now.
Not now.
Not yet.
Right now.
Oh.
Oh, look at that.
Yeah, did you see that?
Okay.
Now where do I go?
Alright, this way.
Oh!
Okay, look at that.
Pure skill.
Yeah, I went.
A card in this plan, draw and pray and drowns them at the
bottom of a large...
Oh, fun fact.
Robo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
What some nice fun facts
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I love me some nice fun facts
For real Ow
It's okay
I was in reverse.
Oh my god, please stop.
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
Okay, where's the next drop?
Why was I going to just go over here now?
Where is that sniper, though?
I'm like climbing the stairs.
But he's like right...
Wait, where is he?
Is he above me?
track of him actually lost track of the sniper all right
we'll wait here
all right I'm gonna assume the missiles not gonna hit me
good I mean it did it I mean I was right I thread the needle
what I told you.
That's smooth.
I said it was going to hit me and it didn't hit me.
It's just that easy, guys.
Wait a minute, it was that, yeah.
It was just that easy.
Dude, I just had to shoot down.
Whoa.
I just...
I hit it?
Oh!
Alright, now I can hit it.
I'm close enough.
Which one's the neck joint?
Oh.
Guys, I might've...
Whoops.
That wasn't the neck joint.
That... That's the neck joint.
oh my god my little tiny little my tiny little sword
couldn't cut through it
all right i told oh wait this might be the best i've ever
done for this one
look at that zero no hits zero damage look at that guys
didn't get hit at all look at that Don't look at them.
Look at that.
It says zero on the repair cost right here.
Zero.
See that?
Zero in repair costs.
It's a little visual bug, guys.
It's a little visual bug.
It's meant to say the zero was supposed to be up there.
But lagged.
Alright.
Underground exploration.
Here comes the follow-up 621.
See, my accountant would agree with me.
You're going to be exploring depth too.
I'm skipping that.
I already know about depth too.
I know about all the depths.
Just so you know, 621, my radar won't be able to reach the
lower depths.
You'll have to trust your eyes and ears.
Alright, here we go.
No more Walter.
Main system.
Activating combat mode.
All right, let's speedrun this.
Without getting to the actual other ending.
I'm so packed.
Okay, I feel like on my third, oh my god, on the third try,
it's just going to go at the same speed because you can't
really upgrade your Mecca to be better than what it is.
Like, I'm already perfect.
You know?
So I feel like, I think that's the only issue.
You can?
How?
Oh!
How can it be more perfect than what it is?
You can always be fat.
I don't know what you're talking about.
It's not really an ambush when it's like three guys.
It sounds like you found a bailiff's empties.
I'm already the perfect robot.
Perfect build.
This might be a little too fast now.
I think I've all used up all the upgrade chips, isn't that?
Oh, yeah, the elevator.
How do I get back there?
What?
I need a map!
Oh, thank you.
Thank you, wife.
Everything looks the same.
It's just gray walls.
See if you can get access.
Alright.
Whoops.
Alright, yeah, I just want to say, like, what did he say?
And then...
What did the guy say?
I was curious.
I'm like, how did he get timed out?
All right.
Oh, we're never alone when you say that, baby.
Don't lie to me.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I forgot about how fast he was.
Shit Where'd he go?
He's too fast
Where is he?
Oh my god, I've lost track of him.
I actually ah
Okay, okay, okay, I figured about I just gotta keep him down
here
Can't fly up, but we're under the bridge.
Oh, shit.
Oh, that's good.
There we go.
What?
Oh, yeah.
Not fair.
Only main characters can heal.
Oh, she's so fast.
It's like a little.
What is that?
Oh, that's my last repair kit.
Oh, my sense is not...
It's not fast enough!
My sense isn't high enough for these turns!
Ah!
I'll just do that.
Oh, yeah.
Yes!
Oh, I'm the main character.
I'm the main character.
I'm the main character in the story.
Not even close.
Still, I'm the main character.
That's right.
They must have got the cheapest one.
Because I wasn't even stressed.
out.
Not even close.
Must have got a one star.
What the fuck?
Oh, it's this guy again.
Oh, poor content.
Exactly.
Oh, yeah, it's like this way.
Hmm.
Where are you?
Yeah.
Where do you get this assassin?
off.
Huh?
Craigslist?
Alright.
Get these guys out of here.
Because that guy was a Craigslist assassin.
You guys are Timu.
Where am I supposed to go?
Not here.
It has to be here.
Yeah.
Got him off of Fiverr or something.
shit is it not here there's like people down there oh god i
don't remember
oh wait wait i remember now in the ravine yeah yeah yeah i
remember now where we got exceptionally lost look for a
ventilation duct oh my god it's ventilation duct oh shit
and it seems i am no exception okay thank god thank i
remember this part part that took us 20 minutes to five
actually honestly i can just leave them they don't really
matter that much in the grand scheme of things they're just
little babies
all right well i guess we'll just kill the little babies in
game in game in game all right they are getting they are a
little annoying for babies.
Should be like, where is it?
Are you Akko?
Down here?
No, because my jetpack takes me up here.
I thought it was up here.
Up?
Oh!
Up up!
Up!
Is there an uproar?
Behind me?
There's something high?
Oh!
Oh my god, there's a hole!
Everything looks the same on this map, you can't blame me!
It all looks the same!
Oh my god, I swear to god, there's another, oh my, there's a
hole, and another hole.
Oh yeah, no, no, no, no, I remember I had to kill all of
these guys.
The ambush, as they say.
The perfectly crafted ambush that they made for me.
She'll never suspect a thing.
I can just facetank that.
There's no way she'll know that we're all waiting here for
her.
There's no way.
All right, let's search for the holes.
All right, nice.
The defense system is on to us.
We should be able to proceed.
What defense systems?
Tokyo, no!
Defenses are on!
He's poured water all over it.
Alright.
Alright, nice.
Another resupply.
I like watching him fly, tried to leave the window.
It's like, please, like you gotta get like a little
newspaper to fan the fly to the right direction.
But I just fly backwards.
Alright.
I remember her.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I know.
I know you don't have a pilot whatsoever.
Yeah, yeah, I know.
Oh shit!
Oh, clearly I didn't know.
Oh my god.
Never mind.
Yeah, I know.
Let me face take it.
brilliant plan I don't understand it's always worth though
oh no you mean I can't just face that oh shit forgot what
you species has never mind never mind actually have to oh
whoa oh it hits me my bad guys I got too comfortable being
so powerful.
You mean I have to play for real now?
What is this?
Yeah!
What do you mean?
I have to play the game for real now.
You mean my overpowered new K plus mech doesn't live that?
I can't...
I can't coast anymore.
Oh my god.
Are you
serious?
Okay, that should be illegal.
Okay, it's fine.
Alright, it's fine.
Woo!
Oh shit
All right Just do this just in case he just in case he
touches me
All right
Okay, the moment I stopped face taking it got a little
easier There you go See, I just needed to turn on the
switch.
I just had to, like, turn...
I had to close the subway surfers tab.
Who's new?
As long as I stop face-taking.
Yay!
The moment I press more than three buttons.
All right, easy.
That was a close one.
No new messages.
Aw.
No friends.
Leave me no new messages.
Really, I have all of you.
I can upgrade everything now.
It doesn't really matter what I get at this point.
Okay.
Except for manual aiming.
Fuck that.
Buy everything.
Everything but manual aiming.
Incompose new builds?
What's that?
There's only one build.
What do you mean?
Depth three is next and it's where our intel gets sparse.
It's an underground cave, blocked at the end by a
high-powered laser barrier.
We know about this one.
Wait, there's a...
Wait, there's a gun bigger than Sombra's?
Oh, now you're speaking my language.
Why didn't you start with that?
Why did you start with that?
You gotta speak my language, bro?
Main system activating combat mode Commence mission Alright
Ear shot Okay
Oh it's this way Wait is it this way?
Oh fuck we which way did the robot came from this way Yeah
Yeah I speak meta
What do I say last stream about speaking my language oh yeah
it's snipers oh somber it is meta whoops whoops don't let
them shoot you whoops that might be a little too late all
right Oh, I remember this.
Oh, shit.
This is where I was timed.
Oh, I definitely do so well under pressure, as we all know.
I don't know how to do this.
As I'm so well known for.
Yeah.
All right.
I got through that Did not get the hidden chest ready.
I don't remember
Whoops It's five Oh shit, you're still alive There we go
Whoops Oh, that's a lot of stuff on my screen
All right, we should be close to the entrance right where
the fuck is the entrance?
I'm going round and round.
Where is nobody knows.
I killed them all.
Oh wait, it was below me.
Here it is.
Oh, there it is.
They're really tiny little guys.
Oh, I'm here.
All right, hacking?
Hacking?
All right, time to get timed.
Okay, I do need to get rid of these guys before...
Just so it'll be easier for me to run out.
Oh, yeah, let me just fucking walk to the left.
It's just apparently that easy.
Oh, I don't need it.
I'm trying.
Do you think I'm trying not to fight back?
She's like, please fight back.
What does it look like I'm doing?
My wife thinks I'm pathetic.
Oh, okay.
Is it worth grabbing?
Like, whatever it is.
My wife doesn't think I'm fighting back, but I'm trying my
hardest.
Yeah?
Okay, but, like, how worth it?
Because we haven't changed our build in a while.
Oh, other way?
It looks cool.
But Tokyo, it's so sick, though.
Oh my god, look, it's a mommy and her two kids.
Oh, look, it's...
It's just a little mommy with no kids.
Where?
Oh, no.
Oh, that was close.
That was so close.
Oh, it's at the end of that platform?
End of that one?
The long journey ahead.
Oh, there it is.
Wait, this is just lore.
You guys just made me get lore.
Does lore the entire time?
Always has been.
Other way?
I don't see any other platforms.
That major read.
Oh, it's higher.
Gotcha, major read.
Pull the biggest prank on a VTV.
Look at this platform.
We support those three.
Guys, you gotta be much more specific.
I support a lot of things.
Oh,
these guys are mining.
Can I not kill them?
Oh, my God.
No, I can't.
It's just chilling.
Chewed.
Hey, guys.
Oh, I'm so sorry!
This is that one?
I pushed him a little bit.
He got angry.
I don't see a chest here.
Where could it be?
I went through that platform.
I mean, I'll just kill this guy just for fun, I guess.
Oh, wait.
You're supposed to die.
Wait a minute.
How are you still alive?
I guess I'll stab you.
Guys, they need to put yellow blood.
paint on this chest.
No, they 100% do.
Alright, I'll go the other way.
At least I took down all the defenses.
Oh, is it over there?
Is it these guys guarding it?
There's like some guys on the platform.
Surely you're guarding something important, right?
I swear to God, if it's lore again, I... Are you fucking
dead?
I forgot to give it to the one guy!
The one
sniping oh my god actually forgot to get rid of this one
shoulder ammunition at 30 okay why the fuck is i threw 20
missiles on him too i swear to you guys this lore again this
looks like lore oh my god ha ha made it made a read again no
no no
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, there you go.
Okay, I made it, I made it, I made it, I made it.
I made a read.
Guys, guys, I'm this close to abandoning the mission, guys.
I'm this close.
There is one.
I just forgot which platform.
Oh my god, it's over there.
Is it that one?
Oh my god, it has to be that one.
That, oh no, no, okay.
That actually looks like a chest and not a lot, not lore.
Oh my god, finally.
After getting baited.
by all the breeding.
There it is.
All right, now I can go.
Oh, my God.
Was that right above?
It was right above us.
That was the whole, guys.
Guys, guys.
It was literally, it was literally right here.
Thank you.
Thank you for the raid.
It was.
was there.
Who was, like, wrong?
I went left first, and then someone was like, oh, Doki,
wrong way.
Wrong way.
That's not the right.
You gotta go right side, Doki.
Alright, where's the last chest?
I might as well grab it.
Where is it?
I just had to take a more scenic route there's
no you can't say down that plot what do you mean down that
platform down over there is there actually something over
there i i don't know why i don't know why i even humor you i
oh whoops i don't even know why i even tried major walk
What a major look.
I don't think there is anymore.
It's one of the platforms higher up on the Elks.
I fucking, how many more platforms can there be?
I feel like I've done all of them.
There can't be more platforms left for me to explore.
This is not very wheelchair.
accessible, I will say.
Alright, so I'm back to where I was.
It's near the start on the right.
Alright.
Well.
Alright, if you say so.
It's near the start on the right.
Where did I start off?
I just gotta find the start on the right.
Alright.
Everything looks the same.
You really think I'm going to be able to find the start
on...
Is that the start?
Am I right or you're right?
That's the start.
This is the start.
Oh you saw it.
Oh you sure you did.
Sure you saw it.
The stage right.
What the fuck the stage right even mean?
Oh I'm just going to kill this guy just for fun.
Fuck it.
It's right there, though.
Can you not see it?
I just see a lot of kids, though.
I just...
There were a lot of kids there.
Guys, I'm at 30% ammo.
Oh, my God.
Is that it?
Is that it over there?
Guarded by the children.
Yes, the best defense kids.
Because, like, surely no one's going to kill the kids for
loot.
No!
The thing is, he doesn't know I'll do anything for loot.
In fact, it's even better that you put the kids to guard
this.
Makes my life easier.
Oh, thank god.
I thank god that one was quick.
Oh my god.
door stuck.
All right, now we can now that the main mission is cleared,
we can do the side quest now.
Oh, it's going to be hard to backtrack.
I already forgot how to fuck.
I'm going to I'm going to forget how to navigate this.
Really, it's not going to.
Whoa, imagine if I could actually Oh my god, I forgot how
hard this was!
621, there's no time.
I can't see.
No, no!
I can't fucking do this!
Everybody's so fast now!
Oh, please tell me it's my chest safe.
Oh, please tell me it saves.
I think I'm going to die here.
This is my coffin.
I made my grave.
Oh, Eddie heals.
Give him everything.
Give this man as many things as he was.
He deserves his birthday.
Oh, my God.
Used all my misdemeanor on the children.
I used all my ammunition on the kids.
I...
I might have messed up Oh,
please please I hope oh, please tell me I have my stuff
still This is where the children I've used all my big booms
on the kids Oh, no, wait, okay, it's right here
What if I...
Sure, I'll make it!
It would have been so cool if I did.
It would have been...
You have to admit, it would have been cool though.
There we go.
What?
Okay, that's good.
Bullshit!
That's what...
Ref!
Check the vines!
There we go.
Which way is my way?
Is it this way?
How?
Oh my god, that's way.
Look, hack, hack, hack.
I put all my upgrades on hack.
Okay.
You've got a job to do 621.
Don't fail me now.
Raven, you have to get clear.
Oh, I'm trying.
It's gonna blow.
Grace for impact.
Oh, I slept!
I slept!
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
It went too fast.
It was through that banana peel there.
There you see.
Yeah.
It's just now wheelchair accessible.
The coral's near.
That's another solid milestone in our work.
It's on them.
There's oil on the tracks.
They don't think about the wheelchair.
How could they do this to me?
Yeah, you guys see the blue shell?
Guys, guys, there was a banana.
There were banana peels, oil, rocks.
It was just not wheelchair accessible.
What can I say?
The enforcement system silent at least.
Tried to take 621 with it.
Good thing it failed.
Well, that deals with the PCA What about the corpse?
Archibus told us to wait before entering Terra Incognita.
So you're close then.
The corpse won't be helping each other over the finish line.
Yeah.
Archibus wants Balaam out of the picture first.
Looks like Archibus is gonna win the race no matter what.
Short-term, maybe.
But I think 6-2-1 is going to be the key in the end.
And that's why I shouldn't be the one who's going to be.
to choose which jobs we take sounds risky or friends maybe
all right that's enough we've already what heard this before
all right this is where we have to take a different mission
right no new messages oh yeah thank god thank god did the
hard one first at last past jokie has done something
It was sent by middle flower.
Thank fucking god.
Polly, she did something right.
Alright, here we go.
Pastor Kipali gave me a freebie.
Alright, ambush the Vespers.
I'm like, oh, the Obama meme.
I'll get straight to the point.
Archibus leads the corporate forces.
Well, this is not new, but also new.
But they're still human, tired from the endless conflict
between powers.
From their key forces.
We want you to eliminate two of the Vespers numbered
officers.
V5 Hawkins, their officer overseeing the Transport Corps.
V8 Pater is agitant.
we'll use false information to lure them out from their
depth to survey then ambush them spreading misinformation i
will assist you on this mission i'm not good opportunity to
catch up with a veteran i look forward to your favorable
response raven oh yeah did you guys see the scalpers of
pokemon worlds by the way i had like some guy you know how
like okay so you know okay so there's Pokemon World slash
Pokemon XP going on uh right now um at the uh in San
Francisco oh yeah the back okay I think the backpack one is
a little it's pretty crazy uh honestly I think the I think
the backpack one is a little like too much honestly uh but
wait let me show you guys sorry I just saw that I saw that
my phone I was like oh yeah forgot about that so there's
like guys who buy it I think it's like if they get a ticket
to get a backpack for it there's an exclusive backpack for
Pokemon world slash XP and then literally they put they put
put like this little they put for sale on the backpack while
walking around San Francisco for anyone that hasn't got it
yet because it's an exclusive backpack that you can get only
if you have the I thing is like only if you have the VIP
tickets to the Pokemon worlds basically and uh and so like
and apparently for the Pokemon Center um you have like
reservation time slots so even if you like reserve a
specific time slot to go into the Pokemon Center it takes
around two to three hours two to three hours in the line for
your reservation spot so you'll get that for if you have a
reservation spot to go to the pokemon center um at 4 30 uh
and you make you get you start lining up at 4 20.
you're in that line for two to three hours to get into the
pokemon center and then when you check out it's another hour
to check out so look at this yeah it's a lot of exclusive
merch and there's some merch that you can only have a
lottery to even have a chance to purchase it that's fucking
great like look at that this is the checkout line by the way
that's the line to check out but like anyway so there's a
lot of people who are scalping uh the uh pokemon like the
exclusive merch from Pokemon the XP slash worlds and they're
just sitting outside just sitting there scalping the stuff
let me show you I just saw a picture of it and I was like oh
my god that's actually so that's so shameless like they're
sitting outside the convention center with all the stuff
they bought with a suitcase of everything they bought from
the Pokemon center and just selling it outside the
convention center I think That's fucking shameless as well.
Like, it's just so sad.
Like, and it was, and it's so hard, by the way, it's really
hard to even get tickets to Pokemon X.
Like, people were complaining about how difficult it was to
get Pokemon XP tickets to even, like, go to the convention.
Or even, like, like, people, like, even get a ticket to go
to the convention, because to reserve a ticket, it was so...
difficult to reserve tickets because you can't scalp tickets
at all that's the thing like scalpers could not even scalp
the pokemon convention tickets but but like so they'll just
scalp the merch that you can get from the pokemon center
yeah the fact that they're selling outside the convention is
crazy i just think that's that's the that's like the most
shameless part and it's like the only way to even get these
this merch um like i said the only way to get the merch is
literally you have to you have to be at the convention like
you have to be in the convention and reserve a spot
i'm selling like you're selling stuff outside i think it's
crazy that you're selling stuff outside of uh outside the
convention in the suitcases too like that's fucking that's
It's in San Francisco.
I think that's fucking weird.
It's cringe.
I think it's so cringe.
So shameless.
If he's accompanying you in person, he must be planning to
take your measure.
Of course they're upselling.
They lined up three hours for it.
They have to line up three fucking hours to get into the
Pokemon Center.
Oh, he comes plus one, buddy.
They're coming, Raven.
Oh, shit.
God, yes, that's the moment.
Yeah, when it said whenever the moment.
is right i did not realize like they'll be outside my door i
i guess guys i guess that was the right moment guys
here we go whenever the moment's right oh be hello Like,
try, like, Mormons trying to convert me.
I don't know.
I know.
No, no, no, no.
Telling me to come to their church.
Knock, knock.
It's just right now, by the way.
That's the moment.
Right now.
The old-fashioned orientation hasn't let you down.
Okay.
Where's my allies?
Are you even doing anything?
Like, what do you even do?
Oh, wait.
Yeah.
Oh, did I kill this boyfriend?
Well maybe this boyfriend wasn't a pussy.
Your boyfriend wasn't weak as hell.
Then maybe you wouldn't have to cry.
Maybe I'll find a comrade in you yet.
Yeah.
Better has mental issues.
Oh, poor guy.
Now he doesn't have to worry about that anymore.
Look, I sent them both to heaven.
To be fair, it happened so fast I didn't get a chance to
hear what they're saying.
I literally, I just, I just stabbed him and he was dead.
One new message.
Oh, I had a new message.
About the request to attack the Red Guns.
Maybe if he was not so weak, I might be able to hear the
dialogue better.
I don't want to say fighting.
The politicians will be fighting their war now.
Where there's coral, there's blood.
It's okay.
On the third, when we do another rewind time.
When we do another rewind time, I'll be able to process the
dialogue.
Now that I know he's, like, weak as hell.
Don't keep giving the best mental health advice.
Mistakes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, ear shot.
Okay, which one is it?
Okay, ear shot.
Laser.
Split missile.
Where is it?
I don't see the ear shot.
I passed it.
Delivery boy.
Must have passed it again.
Oh, there it is.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
It's like almost nothing.
Alright, let's see what it looks like.
Oh, that's a big boom.
Wait.
That is a big boom.
Alright.
wow oh wow that's the biggest boy let's put both of these
booms we'll do one we'll just have one of them on just in
case at deep intense fine limit your pursuer there monkey
see boom monkey see monkey boom picking up where we left off
now that you've dealt with the laser barrier we can explore
deeper underground is this the same mission We've received a
request from Archibus to continue the advance survey.
We do miss fire conflict wherever we go.
You knew the terms and conditions.
We've received some concerning information that an AC has
been quietly following your trail.
Thank you for the super chat.
They thank you.
Archibus cannot tolerate unauthorized surveys that will put
its coral interests at risk.
Eliminate them What do you mean, dude?
Are we blessed to spark conflict wherever we go?
You mean that?
Liberation Front?
Another mercenary?
Alright, here we go.
Okay, after this mission, we gotta walk, Dad.
He has to poop, right?
Like, I gave him two more hours.
There's no way.
Okay.
All right, here we go.
He has to poop after two hours.
I gave him two hours leeway.
No, he's sleeping right now.
He's actually just chilling.
What was that?
Oh, it's Lore.
God, he got me again.
again, though.
I feel like my brain has absolutely been brain-riding from
all the...
From all the shorts that I've been watching.
I actually feel like I should... I should start reading
again.
I should skip all this.
Like, I feel like I am seeing negative effects of Brain rot.
What is Rusty?
I'll get to see.
My on and off boyfriend.
Don't worry, it's just, you know, it's just foreplay what
we're doing.
My on and off again husband.
Guys, it's just, guys, we're not actually fighting.
It's just foreplay.
I hate to say it, but Yeah?
Robicon still needs me.
You see, he still calls me buddy.
It's our cute nicknames for each other.
You?
I thought what you said last day.
You, right, Rusty?
Oh, whoa!
You're what?
Yeah, Rusty?
There you go.
He's like stuck in this corner.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Dude, save that in bed.
Whoa.
Oh my god, he's...
I feel like he's a lot faster.
Or I can't tell.
He might be a lot faster now.
Wait,
what?
Is there two of you?
Wait, what the...
Who's he?
Who's he, Rusty?
Wait a minute!
Rusty!
We agreed.
We gotta talk about this when you wanna bring a third
person!
Okay.
I
This is a partnership you gotta let me yeah, we gotta have
discussion about this
Get in the chair, I'm picking up a major coral response
coming from the bottom of the pit Let's keep moving Raven I
can't believe yeah, he was the guy that was with I thought
he was only getting close closer to me.
Last mission.
Just to twist a knife.
I need to prepare before the course of the day.
I don't need a chair.
We're in a wheelchair.
Head back to base and rest up.
Look, just because I'm in a wheelchair doesn't mean...
Doesn't mean you can just bring a third person.
person into this relationship.
Raven.
I see them so clearly.
The voices of the Coral.
My family.
Brothers and sisters consumed by the fighters of Ibis.
Only a few survived.
But after all this time...
It's two wheels!
Not three!
...
Your family's still alive.
Yeah?
Let me tell you a story before you go.
There once was a scientist.
Oh, it's this one again.
He abandoned his family to delve into the secrets of Coral.
Honestly, I feel like I didn't have a chance to process the
earshot.
weapon.
I feel like I'm too busy fighting my on and off yet husband.
We're just going through a rough patch.
Died with no regrets.
There's a lesson in this story.
Damn, I want to hear Ian.
I want him to vet.
You know, I gotta let him vet.
Story time's over.
It's time for work.
From his free therapy.
Reach to Coral Convergence.
Alright, this time, this mission, and then we walked out.
Because we completed the last one so fast.
Oh shit, wait, fuck, I hate this.
I hate this one.
I forgot.
This mission sucked.
621.
From here on out, I...
Yeah?
I love you?
Just trust your instincts.
It's okay, Dad.
I know it's very hard to say.
I know it's very hard to say because you just have so much
trouble with that word, right?
Right?
Don't worry.
He'll eventually say it, guys.
He'll say it, guys.
He obviously really wants to say it.
It's just, look, he's been through a lot.
It's really hard for him to say that word.
a very difficult word guys it's a very very hard work and
like and he's like he has like he has like stutters and he
does this less dyslexic and everything guys gosh shit i
remember this this one doesn't suck
just wait looks like the drones are keeping them busy
we'll wait I can wait I don't remember which one was easier
not gonna lie they were both pretty fucking frustrating
because I fought them here I brought them to this pit
it's okay it takes them forever I'd rather I have them chip
off some damage off of them
we got them Moonlight Blade.
We already did.
Don't worry, we did.
Over there.
I was thinking maybe I could, like, shoot him when he gets
stunned, too.
He saw me?
How?
Whoops!
That's not what I wanted to do.
Come in.
The Raven has landed.
Requesting backup.
I need to kill him before.
Oh, you fucking bitch.
Okay.
Okay, this is it.
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
We got him in the corner.
What the fuck?
Where did you come from?
There we go.
Oh, that was fast.
Okay, God, I did the corner trick.
Oh my god.
That wasn't pretty.
Oh.
That's right.
Get coroner.
Easy.
That's right.
Get coroner.
It's like a street fighter all over again.
I took him into the coroner.
I corner camped him.
All right, we're not going that way.
I remember the fucking wheelies.
Okay, we'll let them do the thing.
lore and then we'll go to the bridge that's right i use
street fighter strad on them
whoops miss oh he's coming back he rotated yeah up
You mean he turned around Oh, yeah, I remember how he's at
the wall here It's like this way Oh Nearly there six two one
Yeah Just hugged the wall.
Alright.
Let's go.
Just that easy.
That's right.
Speed run.
We're here?
Archibus will be here soon.
Investigate before they arrive.
I forgot which way to go.
Oh, this way.
There's no roads.
How is supposed to know it was this way?
Oh, it's millennia time.
Oh, never mind.
I don't know.
It's Gundam millennia.
What's what?
Round two.
Unidentified machine overhead.
Mecha Melania.
Here we go again.
I didn't think I'd see your face again.
Mechalania.
Ooh, that's good.
That's a good one.
Get ready, 6-2-1.
If she kills me, it's a hate crime because I'm in a
wheelchair.
And she can get cancelled.
for that.
Holy shit, holy shit, what is this?
First hit already?
Oh my god.
Yeah,
I just land that.
Yeah.
I know.
What?
Like, it's hard?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, God.
Oh, oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I keep flying.
Don't fall in here.
Oh,
shit.
I think she's hitting me.
Oh.
oh yeah she's hitting me she's hitting me where did she go
no I can't it was a one-time thing I don't know how to
replicate it okay
is it
Where did she go?
Oh, I kept...
First try!
Oh, I have to have to fight her all over again, too.
That's the worst part.
Is it over?
Yeah, it's that easy.
It's fading.
Huh.
I'm the OG Raven, of course.
Inherited from its creators.
Voices from the past.
Fading in her.
Oh!
Right behind me.
It's because she didn't want to commit a hate crime.
She knew she was gonna get cancelled.
And you said wheelchair build was bad.
Was F tier.
Now you fucking rat.
I'm just jealous.
Oh, that tuning big boom and pow really paid off.
and of course of course what let's not forget the hounds
master either walter not again thought we're gonna change
the past oh i'm thinking of a super chat thank you thank you
archibus seized control of the coral and its occupying
forces swiftly commandeered the entirety of institute city
There, they discovered a wealth of forgotten relics.
Among them, experimental weapons that the Institute kept
secret, fearing they were beyond human control.
A group of sea weapons bearing the name of the Central Coral
Control System.
The Ibis series.
Archivist also claimed a towering coral siphon Abandoned
since the fires The vascular plant Now they toil to repair
the plant And extend its reach Boy time, thank you for the
super chat Thank you, thank you, Doki Raven That's me The
Liberation Front no longer had the power to stop them
of war continue to smolder as the end drew near
oh i'm captured again i found a message addressed to you
back into the slums i'll go decoding and playing back guys
i'm having a feeling i'm not changing my past
back into the slums i go main system activating combat mode
i'll jailbreak and then and then dad can poop i found some
coordinates in the ac systems oh my gosh as i learned how to
walk i can't believe they put us on the sewer duty
let's just shoot him and then you should avoid conan as much
as possible raven i'm afraid this ac is no match for your
abilities Oh, that's not right.
Oh my god, it's a miracle.
It's a Christmas miracle.
I can walk now.
Oh, wait, I forgot this part.
This area fucking sucks.
Alright, goodbye.
This AC should have just enough propulsion.
Where is it?
Oh, it's over here.
Alright, I swear.
Oh, maybe I should not have...
Whoops.
If I have a bad idea.
It's fine.
You don't know I'm here, right?
Surely not.
Evade?
What's that?
I don't think I've heard that word before.
Just kill him all.
Fuck it.
Wait, Peter's alive?
I thought I killed you!
I mean, how could I do that?
That's all I've been doing.
Nothing has changed in my strategy.
Don't worry.
They won't spot me.
Okay, maybe I should actually.
Oh, shit!
It's okay, they didn't spot me.
Guys, I think they spotted me.
I...
The world doesn't run over.
Where?
I don't want...
I really don't.
We're not far from our destination, Raven.
What?
How do I even get up there?
I...
I'm...
My trusters...
You've got eyes on the independent mark.
No, you don't.
No!
Why does my legs betray me?
My new legs!
My new legs can't go up!
No.
Alright, fuck this.
Let me just kill you.
Alright, give me a...
I'm too short!
Ah!
There you go.
I'm okay.
Oh shit!
Okay, I'm fine.
Get up, please.
The rendezvous point is really right there.
What the fuck?
It's okay, I'm here.
Just shooting down.
All right, here we go.
Don't worry, he's here to upbees.
Upbees.
Wait, that's not the upbees I was looking for.
Wait a minute.
I was...
Push my upbees.
Oh, shit!
All right.
Give me a sec.
There we go.
Thank you.
I'm glad he waited.
I...
I was like, wait a minute!
Give me a second!
He's like, okay.
Hey, Taurus.
You're having a little trouble?
Carla.
Walter.
He asked me to look after you.
Don't mind if I do...
Oh, thank God.
Carla's here to save me before I kill her.
There's another AC.
Three.
Carla, Carla, Carla, Carla, they're all here.
Carla, Carla, why are they all running at me when you're
over there?
Carla, oh, thank you, Carla.
See, guys, someone was like, maybe you should save your
ammo.
Look at that.
Don't need to save shit.
There's plenty of ammo to spare.
Looks like we're clear.
Better book it before more company shows up.
Thank you, Auntie Kaya.
Vee!
Get to be back into my bot.
Nice.
See, look at that.
And I didn't waste any money.
If I don't make money, I didn't waste it.
augmented human c462 all right i'll walk dad now all right
guys i'll bear back god make sure he poops this time i'll be
back guys back
in your old as you write that down too you just be like
we're
here's the text option oh all right you deserve to know what
we've been fighting for dad i'll get you introduced
all right okay walking dad a key a key my okay walking okay
maybe walking my dog just so it's not out of context walking
my dog okay we're back guys I'm
I'm back
cozy thank you for the super chat thank you thank you all
right so a little recap with what happened for this one
we're not following we're like audio only viewers you know
like they're just listening to a podcast right now while
they're working so he pooped he pooped uh decided to take
him to the closest dog park because i figured usually when i
take him there he in and out super fast uh he sees the patch
of grass peas poops done um that didn't happen as you guys
can see that it took me a while to come back to my apartment
uh rumor they give us super chat thank you thank you so so i
got there um there were a lot of other dogs there i didn't
expect any other dogs there at this time i don't know
usually it's like a gamble if there's dogs there or not so
sometimes whenever i go there usually it's like 70 i'm there
by myself but uh when i go there there dogs there um and
then uh and obviously uh we got there dad peed first thing
he does he pees and i was like all right the the routine the
pattern pee poop done that's all i need but then he peed and
he's like yay other dogs wait is that a pretty woman in
front of me whoa um and then didn't give a fuck about the
other dogs uh so he went straight to the other owner and see
the issue is that when there's other dogs there's other
owners so like i didn't i wasn't worried about the other
dogs i was worried about the other owners because he gets
very distracted uh when he sees the other owners so you know
you beeline straight to the to a female owner I was like,
yes, you want to pet me.
I'm so cute.
Yes.
I was like, oh, no.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, now he's never gonna poop.
And then, and then the owner was like, you know what would
be a good time right now?
If I bring out the squeaky toy.
And it's like, now is a good time to play fetch.
He could say that you found yourself in this shitty
situation.
Gusty, you're a super champ.
Thank you.
And he's like, oh yeah, baby.
It is time to play fetch.
Oh, and is that a squeaky toy?
Maybe you should ask me up for dinner first.
So, I just stood there watching her just play fetch with my
dog and then obviously he's not going to be pooping oh and
then he stopped in the middle of the bench i was like is
this it is this it and then he peed again i don't even think
there's any peed left in the tank i think he was just he's
like well but what if maybe just a little like a little
squirt he's like i'm pooping and i'm like i'm ready to go
again
And then another dog came in, a new dog came in, a dog came
over, greeted the other dogs, went to the corner, straight
to poop, straight to pooping.
I was like, why can't you do that?
He, that, the first day, first day back, technically, uh,
second day back, and he's already rage baiting me.
He's already, he knows how it gets my buttons going.
He already knows, he's like, I'm the rage baiter.
A new dog comes in, greets the other dogs, goes straight to
the corner, poops.
Yeah, right to business.
And I'm like, why can't you do that?
Why can't you, why can't you, why can't you just go straight
to the corner, poop?
And then it started raining.
is closing the poop window is closing because he would he
refuses to do anything when it's raining and i was like
you're not leaving and the other early is like oh we got oh
gosh we have to go it's raining now that's like you're not
leaving you're not leaving dad i'm not we're gonna We're
gonna take this.
This is the perfect opportunity.
The window is closing, but all the other pet owners, all the
dogs, all the owners, they're leaving.
So it's just you and me, and you have to poop now.
so there's just me and him in the brain he was like he
started smelling and then he peed third time there's nothing
in I know that you're just fucking with me at this point you
know what I want and you're like oh am I gonna I'm sniffing
around this is it I'm sniffing around and he fucking squats
And he's like, oh, that's just pee.
You thought that was poop.
And then I was like, we're not leaving.
Keep on smelling the grass.
And then he finally gets into the squatting sitting
position.
And then it was diarrhea.
Yeah.
I was like
that's it I got the bad ending he finally ults I was just
like oh he's I was so excited I was like oh my god he's
getting into position and then diarrhea it had to pick it up
because I didn't want to get in trouble because it was at
the dog park and you're supposed, if they have they like,
you remember the poop DNA remember when they have my dog's
poop DNA, poop files in the system if I don't pick it up
they would scrape the poop They would scrape the poop and
then I would get fined if I don't pick it up.
So I had to pick up the diarrhea because I didn't want to
get fined because his poop is in the system.
Yeah, I don't want the track being down.
They have his misrecords, guys.
It's still a wild concept.
I'm going to pick up the diarrhea.
But he pooped.
At least he pooped.
I just can't trust the rain to wash it out properly.
I can't trust it.
I just I just don't want to get fined because my landlord
would get will get the email that I got fined so I just I
don't want to risk it all my landlord to be like what is
this dog poop fine that I got in my email so yeah I'm back
he he did it though at least you fucking did it all right
let's go to the next mission at least i don't have to worry
about that anymore
the main goal is achieved but at what cost
Vibus burnt the planet up.
A secret organization formed.
Hiding in the ashes.
Overseer.
The Association of Observers.
They monitored the coral's growth.
Ready to burn it before the collapse came.
That was their mission.
Our mission.
Me.
At least it wasn't in the apartment.
True.
It's the little things.
is the little things it's time for me to get back to my real
work
you've been to xylem before right the floating city created
by the Institute it's hiding a secret a little something to
prepare against the coming collapse we need to get to it and
fast our ID's entire team of hackers is going to be working
to take control of xylem I archivist when they come running
to see what we're up to I did feel like I was in an
unskippable cutscene in real life I couldn't end this
cutscene I had to just stand there and wait until it's over
it was an IRL unskippable cutscene
Association of observers.
Especially I watched the owner play with my dog and all I
could do was just stand there and wait.
Main system activating combat mode.
Get into position tourist it's time.
Oh no not again
Oh, shit.
Oh, backing up.
Chief, I've cracked some of the defense systems.
Good job, Channy.
That'll buy us some time.
Looks like you're in position.
All right, here we go.
This is the defense mission.
This is when I had the moon blade for the first time.
I'm picking up an archivist and cheese mod.
Well, guys have showed up early.
Looks like you're up already, Taurus.
Whoops.
Did I hit him?
I did.
I mean, that's five.
Yeah.
I did.
I'll support you.
Don't let them near the tower, Taurus.
I'm trying.
I swear to God.
All right, at least like...
It's fast.
Use them if you need the help.
All right, I'm in the middle.
Oh, shit.
There we go.
Snipes!
Oh my gosh.
Four minutes of this.
Four minutes left.
The system is ours, tourist.
Is it...
Is that hit?
I don't know.
I missed that.
I was so big!
Oh no, I ran out of ammo.
That's not good.
This is Doki experience.
How did I miss?
Every time.
Oh, shit.
Oh.
Only one minute has passed?
That's fine.
Eh.
Three more minutes.
Hang in there, tourist.
Am I used the turrets?
Show up the entire time.
Oh no.
Oh, I don't know if that hits.
Oh, that hits.
I think that hit.
Oh, they run out?
Oh, no.
Of course they do.
I can't have any good thing in life.
Oops.
I mean, that should be right.
Not that.
That doesn't hit him!
Oh my god.
I'll have the other turret up.
Oh, shit.
I remember these.
Oh!
Make sure you don't miss, Taurus.
Guys!
Guys, it looks like I died.
I didn't miss.
Make sure you don't miss I definitely totally did not Oh my
god Oh my god Left shoulder ammunition Oh no Oh no it's
getting closer You've been working like a dog Must be
Walters influence Guys being real slave track
Okay, just one down.
Guys, I definitely did not miss.
When he said make sure that he don't miss, definitely didn't
happen.
I did the one thing she told me to do.
Just like Rusty.
have full admin access just a little more tourist exactly
how rusty you envisioned
okay this is actually bush and like what the fuck like right
hand ammunition at 50% definitely make sure I didn't miss
guys oh shit oh there you go Easy.
So easy.
Didn't miss at all.
Good job holding out, Taurus.
Now I'll show you what this city really is.
Yippee!
The water line's falling.
The whole city's rising.
It's so cool every single time.
I should order food.
Give me a second.
I haven't ordered food after this one Haven't had lunch yet
Should get something to eat I don't know what to eat though.
I had pizza last night
I give you the colony ship silent
Walter's parting gift
yeah I surprised random animals so fast though did not
expect that all right while you filled me in I'm gonna look
at what's the order I keep craving a bit of poker maybe it
won't be long before
it's too late of course We can't just walk up to the plan in
light of match No, we're going to need something bigger A
lot bigger Oh wait, this is good Oh, I'm gonna get this
Actually But I have that I have Ooh I'm gonna try this This
place This is new, I haven't seen this place before It's
like a Restaurant that's just dead They catered to Takoyaki.
It looks good.
The corporations want only to devour the coral.
The observers fear the coral and want only to eradicate it.
Yeah, my waifu?
Raven.
I need to ask you something.
Anything.
Anything for you.
I'll always do everything you want me to do, and I'll never
betray you.
It'll never happen.
The voice is in my head.
Said she loves me.
If I do this for her, she's got something exciting for me
planned today.
Let's see.
I'm trying to figure out which flavor I want for my
Takoyaki.
I'm gonna try this one It says fan fame It says like number
one Alright Or this is new Never tried it before New place
The voices in my head said if I kill you She'll marry me I
eliminate Cinder Carla No hesitation
She loves me She says she loves me She loves me!
He told me to kill.
Always trust the voices!
Sorry, sorry.
The only way to stop the Xylons' ascent is by seizing
control of its systems.
And that means we have only one choice.
We'll take advantage of the confusion while the corporations
and Overseer are fighting.
And eliminate Carla.
I understand how you feel about betraying Walters' last
wishes and taking on Carla.
But still, I want you to give me a chance.
Of course.
I'll always give you a chance.
I'll never betray you, my waifu.
Of course.
Never.
I've never done it.
I'll never do it.
Why would the voices like that?
Why would the voices lie to me?
She's always been in my head the entire time.
Thank you.
Of course.
I would never pick any other choice.
Ever.
Oh yeah, now that dad's here, I should just be like...
No shit.
Putting me in an unscapable cutscene.
Alright, now this is new.
See?
She'll always support me!
She'll always be there for me.
I have nothing to shoot right now.
Whoa!
That was a little Frieza moment right there.
I'm gonna let them shoot him, I guess.
Does it really matter?
I don't get this guy, I don't know what this guy is doing.
I'll just let them shoot him first before I do anything.
Wait, where is he?
Is that him?
No, that's just a regular guy.
Oh, that's him!
Alright, here he is.
How dare you just walk slowly backwards?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You don't get to use me in the corner!
Whoops.
Get out of here!
That's fucking right!
Snail!
You may have won this battle, but I'll win the war.
Oh, what war?
The war's gonna be over before you're back.
That's right.
That's my corner.
Alright, get this guy out of here.
Salted the snail.
For them, they give us a super chat.
Thank you.
Do you like that handshake?
Love.
I don't need money.
I have love.
What's...
What is this?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Oh, whoa, whoa!
Jeez, oh my god, it was right next to me.
What do you mean it was right... what do you mean it was
right next to me!
It's nighttime!
Okay, I'm okay, I'm okay I'll just get Stunlock
Guys, what do you mean it was a bad thing?
That idea just sat next to the fucking paralyzer.
Surely there's a resupply, right?
Surely my wife got me a resupply for me, right?
Surely she's got me, right?
Wife?
My beautiful wife?
Are you?
all right you're gonna send the supply drop any moment now
right here oh wait why is there two of you uh
oh i'm ready for the supply drop I'm so ready for it!
Oh!
It's coming any moment, right?
It's right here!
Oh my god.
No, I'm a vampire.
Well, he didn't.
handle the rest he didn't handle the rest
okay now now i know to kill him first okay i gotta kill him
first at least i got Carla you know what we're dealing with
pin that tourist down all right tank on tank violence let's
go oh the tank can also fly
Okay, this is a little unfair, though.
I can't see anything.
Oh my god!
Where did he go?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, what is this?
Ah, this combo!
I mean, I got him.
God damn.
Thank you.
Wheelchair versus wheelchair.
The wobble.
This is not fair.
I am.
At least go and get into mech form and make this fair.
The door is down.
Oh, my god.
Walter told me, you know.
Looks like you made a friend of your own.
But it's good to make a choice.
You sit on the fence and you make no enemies.
Or friends.
I might actually have to...
Okay.
okay okay okay give me give me a sec Skyla oh my god you've
done it now tourist times like this I can't help but laugh
oh my god anything anything reload please
Oh Please no Carla you bitch Oh my
god, I just one hit just just one hit He fucking runs away
He's a state for dessert tourist
Oh my god, oh my god, I got hit I got it!
I got it!
All right, it's fine.
It's fine.
We did it.
We got it.
That's not to say.
I got it.
Yeah, I don't know.
Seems like, oh, wait, what?
Wait, what?
There's no stopping the ship now.
Last job.
Daddy.
You're dead.
You should I should be winning
Chatty now I thought I killed you Control-A-L-Delete
She copied chatty Liar never trust I knew I shouldn't have
trusted her Oh, all Carla does is lie I knew it.
No new messages.
All women too is live.
Toki, you're a woman too.
Carla had planned living.
Even her own death.
Just like Walter, they both wanted someone to inherit their
legacy.
The Rupakonians are continuing to resist the corporations on
the ground.
The potential of humanity in Coral isn't the only thing we
have to protect.
Raven, there has to be something we can do.
I can't believe it.
Kappa sleeps you with backup chatty.
Destroy the drive dock.
Destroy the large Skyrim of Janner is located throughout
the...
Oh, God, this looks like a timed mission.
I...
I'll explain our mission.
Carla's last trick has rendered the xylem inoperable this
feels like a tad I as you guys know I do very well under
pressure as you all know we have to take the whole thing
down the lower drive block is powered by large skirmian
generators distributed throughout the area if we destroy all
the generators and stop the ramjet engine in the upper city
sector then we can crush the xylem into the Ali and Ocean
without impacting human life.
Oh, alright.
Oh, that's good.
I mean, at least she thinks about them, you know?
She thinks about the humans.
I totally believe using your name to rally allies to our
aid.
Sourched skies.
Raven fights on.
I have friends.
No one has shaped Rubicon's destiny as much as you have.
We got our friends.
Come and see what the name Raven means to them.
Oh my god, you united them all.
I'm a leader.
Let's go.
Wait, am I giving everyone wives?
You have a wife, and you have a wife, and you have a wife.
We'll all have voices in their heads, guys.
Everyone's gonna have voices in their heads now.
Let's go.
It looks like the...
I told you we're in the we're on and off again I told you it
was foreplay
look at that there's a future for Rubicon beyond these
scorch skies there is me in oh my The guy looks so ugly next
to him.
The ugly friend they call to make them look more beautiful.
It really does enhance the rest of these species.
Never thought the plan would go so wrong.
But it's good teaming up with you again.
Couldn't have hoped for a better silver lining.
Target's over.
I feel like I went the wrong way a little.
Can't wait for this.
Rusty, shoot him.
Rusty, do something.
Oh my god, I missed.
Rusty, what are you doing?
Okay, Rusty, shoot that one guy.
All right, there.
That's all I ask.
Be my Misha, Rusty.
I know Nice I'm just
broken into Institute City Well, I'll go now
That's right fuck the corpus
Slogan scrawled and ash were never going to change Rubicon
Cinders are alive flame once more oh shit all right i let
him do most of the work look he's gonna care i'm gonna be on
his little backpack he's gonna carry me oh it's over there
how do i get there i feel like if i fall i die
he's so cool Why can't Rusty...
Like, lead me?
Rusty, guide me!
I'm so confused, Rusty!
Oh, it's all the way back there.
Rusty, please!
You're my seeing eye dog!
It's Rusty's fault for not holding my hand.
Sorry, yeah, I was blinded by Rusty, guys.
Who wouldn't be?
I have to see all my hard work paying off guys who wouldn't
be blinded by by this hunk of a bot
oh shit I can all right let me regen my thing real quick I'm
here where
do I go now yellow paint I assume down where's my yellow
paint rusty hold my hand I'm so
confused oh it's this guy oh my god it's like we're oh my
god we're redoing how We met rusty you over how we met rusty
But yeah, it's like memories
Just sat up here
It's like I'm reloading Should go with that area If it works
it works Reloading now I'm
what how does that still hit me
hostiles they're just jealous of our relationship let me
handle the fight you've got a mission to finish hey i'm
counting on you buddy i'm not i'm not counting on you
YouTube buddy oh man this foreplay is getting a little hot
and whoa a little hot and steamy right now
he's so cool yeah that's my husband we're on like a
one-month break that makes it even spicier you know
take me anywhere?
Oh, right down here.
Oh, I did... I was not on the elevator.
I was like, I wasn't on the elevator square.
I was like, why is the elevator not working?
We're just gonna have to chop right now.
I can risk one more, and now chop here.
We're actually gonna have to use our knives or knife hands.
There it is.
Looks like a little maze.
All right, one left.
One more to go.
Get me off the route and get there.
Ask me here somewhere.
Oh, that's, hey, that's a little awkward, so I'm going to
go.
got to blow you up now as if it never happened all generous
guy is this clear oh finally why couldn't you do that when i
was against carla
something said it's straight for your position for me i've
never seen something move that fast
Oh, Rusty's jealous.
He's so jealous right now It's now Oh shit
Wait, he gets a plane?
Oh no, this is that
Okay What the fuck?
Where did you get the budget for that?
That's unfair!
How did he get a budget for a plane?
I'm gonna cut that plane, though.
Oh, shit.
He was smiting.
Oh, God,
he's just doing a little merry-go-round!
One hit?
Oh my god!
One shot, one kill.
Who would have thought that giant laser beam was one shot?
That damage was insane.
Who would have thought?
All right, let's have a lock here.
Oh, that could be a weapon.
I forgot to heal.
That sounds like me.
He's just jealous because I have a husband.
His name is Rusty.
He's just jealous that Rusty didn't pick him.
Oh my god, I'm sorry.
That's right, you wish...
That's right, Rusty picked me!
He's just a jealous X right now.
Oh, no, not again!
Oh, God.
Okay, that move is actually bullshit.
That's bullshit!
Or maybe he's just homophobic.
I don't know.
Honestly, he could just be homophobic, though.
He seems like what?
Yeah!
He probably is.
That's right.
about man don't worry rusty i saved our relationship what
rusty no we can finally be the get there rusty rusty
overstated the snail form thank you mr richard thank you
thank you Thank you.
Are we going to enjoy this game, buddy?
Don't forget, there's a third ending.
Oh, enjoyed that filter.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, Fiction.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I heard about that.
A lot of people are getting old now.
You still have Megatron, at least.
Augmented Human, C-4621.
Entering Standard Mode.
You saved, right?
Guys, guys, guys, he's just, he's just, he faking, he was
just faking his death.
The asylum is beginning.
He was faking his death, guys.
We just need to destroy the ramjet engines.
Let's put an end to this.
So we can elope and get a happily ever after with my wife,
too.
My, my husband and wife.
It's like my husband.
husband and my husband's boyfriend.
That's how it feels.
He's making his death as foreplay.
Guys, it's foreplay.
It's just more foreplay, guys.
By the way, Snow Death and the JP dub actually sounds like
they murdered him in the boot.
And then we never saw the voice actor again.
They were in a super chat Thank you What please destroy the
target
That sounds easy enough Shit how did I get in this hole?
Wrong hole
Just shoot from here
All right
Now what?
I did it.
Don't worry, it's gonna land and water.
That's what Aria said.
You should make sure there's no human casualties.
I did it!
Oh!
What's that?
I saved Rubik's.
Walter?
Is that...
Is that you?
What?
That's me!
One last job, remember?
What?
Dad?
Are you gonna say you love me and you're proud of me?
That's it!
Oh my god, my dad's here to say he's proud of me!
I have to...
Oh my god.
After what?
Dad?
This is just not what I'm saying!
I love me!
Right?
Coral?
Corporal?
Corporations, borders, all of my friends' mission to
eliminate all obstacles.
You're just playing guys!
Dad's just playing!
Whatever they did, you're in danger.
Oh my god, we locked our eyes like that.
Oh, you have a wife, too?
In your head?
Yes.
Kibling for the fire.
We're re-entering Riverlands atmosphere.
Oh my god.
Don't worry, as we all know, I'm very good.
under pressure the war is dead I'll save you it's like it's
like me trying to get a fly on you where did he go oh shit I
lost him I
actually lost him it's okay it's okay Just had a little too
much to drink, guys.
He just...
He had a little too much to drink.
My friend's mission is...
All obstacles.
Jesus Christ!
I need to not look...
Go up.
I need to not do that.
I... I need to stop doing that, guys.
Where is he?
Oh I see it next to you Oh, you can see my what?
Oh my god, family reunion
God my my head said it's not high enough for this shit right
now Oh my god I'm doing worse It doesn't die easy.
Help!
Oh, I walked right into that.
I walked right into the John ass blade.
It's like jump rope.
And you stop walking into this John ass sword.
I need...
That's just high on the coral again.
It's just...
Silly dad.
It's just the usual.
That...
You know, when your dad comes home high and drunk every
night, you know?
That thing.
Like every typical dad, you know?
And you know, when your dad tries to kill you because he
hates...
I love too much... too much coral in him?
Yeah, the usual dad thing.
Whatever they did like every other dad out there, right?
Oh my god, he just dodges it like a bitch
Okay Where is he
Oh my god, it's so hard to see it
Oh, you can't run off, but I can't
What is it?
Hey, it's like all red too That's like the worst part I
can't see because there's so much red on my screen There's
so much red on my screen
Where did he go?
that's it that's it okay wait where's my i need i need to
grab i need to i need to have like high sensitivity for this
i that's it that's up in all right there we go i'm sorry i'm
sorry if you get motion sickness i can't deal with this
anymore my sense is way too low for this fight
If you are prone to motion sickness, I'm sorry.
It's actually the only way.
It's the only way I can keep up.
Oh my god.
This actually is the only way I can fucking keep up with his
movement.
I'm gonna throw up!
Oh my god, he's always like above me!
oh my god and then he flies out of it and then he heals
oh my god you fucking
why can't you do that why did you make me do everything oh
my god i actually walked into that that's actually
unfortunate This is a washing machine fight.
It is.
Practically, it might as well be.
What is this?
You're fucking, you're fucking, I didn't even!
I was right there!
You earned all the credits.
Let the surgery be normal again.
Oh my god, we did it.
Oh.
The washing machine, but...
I had to let go of my limiters, guys.
I'm sorry.
Hey, Dad.
You need some pills for your hangover?
Dad, don't worry.
I got the Coral out.
Don't worry, Dad.
You know what I'm saying, Dad?
Look at you.
It's me.
It's
me.
I mean, more like my wife, you know, like we sort of passed
the friend.
She lives in my head.
We moved in together in my head.
Walter, you want to say anything?
You want to say...
I...
Walter?
Dad?
I...
I love...
Dad!
Dad?
One day, humanity and coral will thrive together.
Because he was proud of me, right?
He was proud that I found a wife that wasn't gonna die
alone.
My dad was also homophobic.
He killed my husband so I could just have my wife another
way raven we'll find it together i mean it's crazy that he
killed my husband and not the wife it's crazy though yay
he's happy that i found found the way He was proud of me in
his final moments.
He's like, finally you won't die a virgin, my son.
I'm so proud of you.
One more to go.
Okay.
My dad was proud of me that I didn't die maidenless.
But technically, if she lives in my head, it might still be,
accomplish what he wants me to accomplish
didn't we solve it i killed my dad for nothing asking dad
for directions life and you said go straight betty thank you
with a super chat thank you
okay i know there's like no one last cut scene one last
ending Raven it's me you took on my hopes yeah of course
anything for you my wife now I want to see and my dad
approves of you
whatever waits ahead I'll support you yes she supports my
dreams
she supports me whatever I do and I get paid I didn't get
paid for killing my wife before Wow I get paid here but I
don't get paid for killing my wife Carla's a bitch she's a
cheapskate oh my god look at that
I only do the new missions when they show up okay that's not
bad call sign Raven authentication complete I got a welter's
part.
I'll wear a welter's head.
Hello, I'm back.
Yeah, it's me.
Looks like you passed the authentication.
You've got plenty of experience.
Look, see, my dad's okay, guys.
He's not dead.
It was all a dream.
I've picked up some work for you already.
See you guys?
It was all a dream.
My dad's alive.
Dad had a crazy dream that you died and everything, but I...
You're okay.
Which one's my dad's head?
It was this one.
There you go.
How?
Alright.
Now I'm gonna roleplay as my dad.
Dad!
It's so crazy.
I had this crazy dream that you died and everything, but I
know you're...
I know you're still alive.
Alright.
Alright, happy?
Alright, we're gonna speedrun this.
Got killed the kid again.
The client doesn't care who does this job.
That AC?
That's my dad you're talking about!
How dare you?
Ultra Instinct Doki Tank coming soon.
For you, a super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, time to kill a child again.
Destroy all of the Rubicon Liberation Front's artillery
placements.
All right.
I'm just gonna speedrun all the way over there.
Doesn't really matter.
This shit does nothing to me.
That's one of the artillery placements.
The front is protected with armor plating.
Attack it from behind.
Hey, where?
Oh shit, it's over there.
There's only one of them.
We can do this.
stab
and then stab there you go all right next up I got speed
right in this area oh stab oh I thought my sword will go
past it I don't know why head to the final site final one
okay wait I can actually turn down.
Sorry, let me turn down the camera settings for you guys.
Oh, no more throwing up.
That corporate dog.
Don't give him another inch.
Alright.
Alright, last one.
That's gonna...
You think that's gonna hurt me a little pea shooter?
Boom!
Gosh.
Tiny little pea gun.
I killed my dad in a dream in a dream He had a jot laser
sword and everything too.
Do you think these are gonna hurt me?
Get pow bunkers Fucking right Speed run
Nice All right next up We just skip all dialogue.
We've heard all of this.
So oh and over again when does the new stuff come in no new
messages it's all right um you know friends my wife gets
here i just talk to my wife oh you want to make sure i
choose make sure no i have to make sure you guys choose the
missions for me make sure you choose the correct missions
for me not not me you mean think from me thinking for myself
if i didn't think for myself i wouldn't be a
streamer main system activating combat mode
why about the dafog mt squad
i mean she has a point guys
Big boom!
That's it.
Your life doesn't matter.
You're just mass produced.
The greatest.
Oh, you think studying me is gonna do anything?
Oh, I guess you're gonna regret that.
I feel everything.
There's one more over there.
You don't even have your own identity.
Look at that.
Look at puny shield.
Cat's laughing.
Boom.
Looks like reinforcements.
Eliminate them.
Yeah.
Alright, nice.
Last guy.
Hey there.
More handshake?
Oh.
This is a lot longer than I expected.
Did it.
Nice.
Easy.
Oh, I can do this with my eyes closed.
Why would you send me on this?
Easy job.
even worth my time.
No new messages.
Alright, next.
Next mission!
I have a drink with my food.
I forgot to order.
Oh, I have to order a drink.
Fuck, I forgot to order a drink.
They didn't come with the food.
Just ordered the one near me.
Oh, wait, this is new.
Sorry, guys.
Let me order a drink real quick.
It's, uh...
So they didn't come with a drink.
I should order something.
Yeah, I finished all the arena.
That's the first thing I did.
Unless there's more later.
Yeah, we're there.
Uh, I really had a mango smoothie.
I'm gonna order something new.
Wait, is this the one that's...
I don't want to drink.
I'll do that.
It's the closest one?
Or closer?
Yeah, this is the closest one.
You know what?
I'll try Guava!
Do I have to select this?
Okay, I'm gonna grab guava juice.
Guava's good.
I won't just order one because if I'm ordering a drink, I
should order like two drinks just in case, you know?
All right.
Whoa, what's this?
Extra toppings?
To my juices?
Whoa.
All right
Three more missions We're speed running this now
Main system activate combat mode These are the ones we've
already done All right, nice It's just that easy.
I'll leave that one guy that I have to tell the tale.
Yeah.
91 damage?
Oh, maybe he should get a new job.
Oh.
Target destroyed.
Onto the next targets.
Oh, I'm glad you know that.
You might as well just leave now.
She's standing for my missiles.
Should have not called him.
Should have called him sick for work.
It's a little bonus.
Look at that.
Easy.
Cool guys.
Don't look at kills.
Bam.
All right.
Next mission.
Keep him coming.
God find my wife.
I don't need you to yapp in my ear.
That's not my wife, shocking.
The only people that can yapp in my ear is my dad.
My, sorry, I guess not my dad.
My wife.
I was like, my dad as I skipped his dialogue.
Got a job for you, 6-2-1.
It's an open call from the Archivist.
Yay, time to kill this kid again.
Guess not my dad, too.
Yippee!
In every life, in every universe, I kill you.
You never live.
Commence mission.
We've got a raid on the target.
Now's the time, 621.
It's just a cat and event.
I'm sorry, kid.
Oh my god, you're so lucky you are so lucky right now You're
so I let you hit me, you know Oh Guys, I'm just playing with
my food I'm just I wanted him to have a life A life-death
experience, you know
That's it for this job.
6-2-1.
After I kill him.
Yo, he got the plot armor.
Unfortunately, this armor only lasts one hit.
There we go.
Next.
I'm here for the new stuff.
Give me my new shit.
That was being shipped.
to the red guns.
Balaam's their Balaam's main force.
And its members are no amateurs.
Wait, it's new?
It's gonna be new?
Alright.
So what do I do?
Oh.
Wait, this is new.
This escort the weaponized...
Yeah, because I destroyed this.
It's the escort, right?
Yeah.
Because I've destroyed it every other town.
Got a job for you, 621.
We've received a request from the Rubicon Liberation Front.
Oh, yeah, a new mission already?
Raven, here's an operation that may be of interest to you.
We want you to escort the Strider, a weaponized mining ship.
There's no end to the corpse invasion.
They've reached the Bonadaya Dunes in Western Valley.
Ah, yes, an escort mission.
Everyone's favorite type of mission.
Before the invasion, the Strider was our mobile base for
extraction.
and distributing coral.
We paid the dozers a fortune to outfit it for combat.
It's too precious an asset to lose.
Hopefully we can count on your assistance.
Looks like we've got conflicting requests about the same
ship.
You'll be doing the work.
You choose.
Alright.
Seems, doesn't seem too bad.
As we all know, we all love We all love escort missions.
All right, here we go.
Commence mission.
Wait, someone's already attacking the ship.
Wait, who?
Whoops, me.
Wait, what?
Oh, guys.
Oh.
Surely my one bullet didn't fuck it up.
Oh, guys.
You think I'll still get paid?
Well,
then.
Do you think I'll still get paid, guys?
Oh, shit.
There we go.
Who down?
I think so.
I mean, it got brought down by these two?
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
Not these two.
Wait, they're here now?
Holy shit.
This early in early game.
all right the wheelie boys oh my god it's everybody they got
everyone it's like the Avengers the crossover of the century
okay that's not fair I have a fucking invisible wall
Oh my god, it's random wheel.
The wheel comes in with a steel chair.
Oh, fuck me, I guess.
There we go.
Oh my god, the stupid...
goddamn wheel.
Why is he so fast?
Oh my god, don't make me a bicep activity again.
No.
Goddamn wheel.
It fucking ricocheted off of me.
Looks like the last of them are nothing on the long range
radar.
Well, but anything on the short range.
But you had a hell of an excuse.
I'll look into this.
You go home and get some rest, 6-2-1.
Yay.
Guys, I still get paid, though.
I showed up.
I showed up, so I still get paid for showing up.
It's all that matters.
Even if the machine was gone, I showed up.
I clocked in.
They still have to pay me for that.
for just being there Raven first up let me apologize that
request to escort the strider turned out to be something
else entirely what I feel wily and I could see you one shot
that thank you for the super chat thank you thank you dude
be careful out there Raven there's more to this there is
all right here we go all right attack the damn complex i
can't wait to fight raven a third time wherever she's gonna
show up you're joining an operation planned by bailum hq
yeah so yeah where did these come up where did where did
they come from heard the good news for walter did you good
sit your ass down and listen
bailum's moving in on the galleon damn complex what are the
liberation front's bases Objective is to destroy their
lifeline and make those sexes shit big for mercy I'll be
sending two good-for-nothing maggots from the red guns gun
four Volta and gun five igwasu All right, you're just gonna
be tagging along on ass wiping duty I'm assigning you the
call sign gun 13 a lucky little number that just I paid me.
Oh my god I got gas allowance Good enough
All right.
I'm gonna go on a field trip.
Gun 13.
I'll stick with 621.
Don't let the red guns teach you bad manners.
Main system.
Activating combat mode.
All right.
Mail and group AC squad red guns.
All right, do we betray them or not?
Because I don't know.
Get in there, you maggots!
What's the plan?
Oh shit, I keep forgetting about these guys.
That's a rerun.
What the fuck?
Holy shit, I got fucking slammed into a wall.
Pick whatever?
I feel like...
Killing them was just easier.
Not gonna lie.
Wait, actually, no it wasn't.
Wait, actually, wait a minute.
How about that?
Yes, you're not a total amateur.
Good for.
Can't say I considered you a pro either.
We do- I just remembered it wasn't easier.
Shape up or ship out.
Six to one.
Redicate the frontline MTs.
I did.
Oh, over there.
I didn't see the other target here.
All right.
Oh, I mean, he's gonna be dead already.
He's fine.
All right.
We got the front line.
That was just the warm-up.
Why didn't he do it?
Wait, 621.
I'm receiving a code and transmission.
Raven.
I represent the Rubicon.
Oh, there we go.
I mean...
We want you to take out the two red guns.
Bucket.
First choice.
Uh...
I get more money?
Nice.
For my offshore bank account.
Your cooperation is a I'll wait a little.
Where is he going up?
Let's not waste their firepower.
I'm gonna wait for...
Where is he going?
Wait, where is he?
I'll kill him first, I guess.
He doesn't know.
What do you mean?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, time out, time out, time out guys.
Come on, why can't we be friends?
Why can't we be friends?
Time out, time out, time out, I was just joking.
I was just, I was, ha ha, you know?
There's some fun.
I'm just fucking around, bro, you know?
It's a prank, bro.
It's just a prank.
Oh, no, they're all here now.
Oh, shit.
They're all here.
What?
He sunlocked my fucking stack.
Okay, it's that fucked up.
Oh, no.
Oh, I fucked up there.
I might be dead, guys.
Guys, it was...
Alright, my food's here.
missed the call for my food.
Yes.
My bad.
Okay.
Sorry.
I missed my.
I can't say stuff when food calls me.
They're like, please answer the buzzer, please.
Wait, give me a sec.
Sorry.
I missed the call for the buzzer.
And he's like, Please, and then he called me and he was
like, please answer the buzzer.
I was like, I'm sorry.
I have really bad connection to the reception too.
In my PC room.
Which is not very helpful.
Not gonna lie.
It's not for the best.
Take care.
There we go.
Surely he's not gonna heal, right?
Surely surely.
Oh, well, maybe he won't heal a second time
Surely won't heal a second time, right?
There we go Wait, where's the other guy?
Oh, he's still all the way there.
I don't know.
I thought he'd be here by now.
Oh, there you go I got that.
I was like, oh shit.
He's gonna show up.
up right here, right now.
Oh, this is bad.
Oh, I've got health.
Oh, I'm just gonna stand up here.
Ah!
This is the combo.
He's just shooting me with his tiny gun.
Are you kidding me?
Fucking...
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Quinn let him finish his cutscene.
That's right.
Skippable dialogue.
Gun four and gun five eliminated.
One on one.
You've ruined our little field trip, Walter.
Yeah.
It's alright.
I have $40 billion in my bank account.
It's okay.
Oh, I got my food.
Oh, and I get my drink in 15 minutes.
in i mean they're just gonna repeat i got you look at my
food
you must be the handler i presume for the independent
mercenary raven honored to make your acquaintance v2 snail i
understand you want to join operation wall climber oh my you
do realize that smash hold on know your place you make a dog
sitter the answer is no my drink's gonna be here in 15 A
little bit of food.
A water, you know.
Ooh, it smells good.
Ooh.
We've been through worse than this.
Very well then.
That's down?
Who's been equally brazen of late?
One that hates the gates?
Oh, it's good.
It's good, Takoyaki.
new message
you got lucky merch so you got a nice punch in oh I got
several punches in bro red guns are going to be first over
the wall have fun watching from the sidelines maybe y'all
like hit the gym more often bro someone's someone slacking
in the in the arm game buddy
I got udon with sesame sauce.
It's good.
It's cold udon, though.
It's pretty good.
This request comes straight from Archibus headquarters.
They want you to assist with a mission the corporations are
calling Operation Wall Climber.
Skipper, skipper.
Oh, back to the wild.
The wild.
is to take the liberation front fortress the wall show them
you're worth the credits six two one we technically they're
paying me a third time to do this
so i think i'm doing pretty good job
main system activating combat mode okay i gotta make sure i
be i see the call for okay we gotta go to the far left we
actually know I can just tank this.
Right?
I can just tank this, right, guys?
Oh, yeah, I can take it.
It's five.
Oh, God!
Oh,
just one?
Oh, I'm gonna show it to them a teach them a less a third
time just one ac clear you haven't fought this one ac bam
that's what you get i'm not just one ac all right get my
cannons next destroy the targets oh which one these two um I
need to get these guys first before I go back there.
I have to go all the way back there.
Oh, I forgot to kill them before.
That's fine.
I think last time is because I had the last playthrough.
I just killed it instantly.
Battling cannons destroyed.
The friendly MT squad will take care of the city.
Eh.
Access the bulkhead and break into the wall.
Oh, there's where I meet Rush.
to you for a third time it's like we met it's their destiny
to always cross paths
all right it's just destiny guys we're always meant to meet
you're fast oh yeah yeah yeah yeah i am oh Ooh.
A numbered Vesper.
He's an elite.
That's Doc's future.
A future Hudson right there.
No, in the third ending, we're gonna say we're gonna be
together forever, right?
In the third ending, he doesn't die.
And it will be together forever.
This is where I stop him from dying.
If I stop my wife from dying, I can stop my husband from
dying too.
And then we'll be a thrupper.
Yeah, right guys?
This is the third ending up.
We stop it from happening.
Make sure you resupply.
Sure.
I'll take a free resupply.
Wow!
You're getting that part.
to keep up with steelheads i'll distract it while you hit
its blinds oh you're so blind that's the stuff walter knows
how to pick them this is b4 understood raven i just got an
update from snail and command you've got enemy
reinforcements incoming if i don't intercept them we're both
toast you need to leave it like this but you'll have to
finish It's like, nothing's just starting!
Oh my god.
This is...
Is it because I chose...
Is it because of how I look?
Is that why you have to leave so fast?
It's actually frustrating.
Trying to get back.
Because I'm trying...
I'm trying to shoot you in the back!
Try and give you back shots right now!
With my misses!
There we go.
Oh my god.
This is the wheelchair, Rusty.
Is it the wheelchair?
Rusty, come on.
I can change, Rusty.
Confirmed.
Juggernaut destroyed.
Operation Wall Climber is a success.
That pilot.
I thought you liked it.
It seems he knew who you really are.
It won't matter.
I've taken that contingency into account.
I don't understand.
No, she won't.
I swear, Rusty, I get...
This time, this time, I get changed.
It'll be different.
After eight plus parts of Arbor Corp, this part is where I
can change.
One new message.
Ark
the plan.
Skip, skip, bump.
Don't keep proving.
Change, ace, change right.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Slow down, guys, guys.
Change is like step by step, guys.
We can't just change like right away.
It's a step by step process.
Looks like switching sides of Galea left and undecided.
One step at a time.
Yeah, Rome wasn't built in a day, you know?
Exactly.
Also, love is about accepting who you are.
If Rusty can't accept it, maybe it just wasn't meant to be.
Are you accepting me?
So I'm gonna say.
Oh, God, not this one.
I hate this mission.
This one sucks.
Honestly.
We have to rescue our captured comrades.
Failure is not an option.
Definitely not a fan of this particular mission.
We're under attack!
The liberation front shot!
And an escort aid to me!
Oh, fucking course I have to do with the escort mission.
Aw, Shaq's like repaired myself.
I hope that doesn't fuck me over later.
I don't think the escort one was very annoying.
I was not a fan of that one.
Is there any more?
Trying to.
Oh, this is that.
That one over here.
This is that one too.
I don't remember the...
The order.
Of where they went.
Still alive at least.
A little rest.
Yeah, no, this mission's ass.
I don't like this mission at all.
Trying to remember where everything's spawned.
Because it has been a while.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Are you kidding me?
Oh my god.
I actually got trolled here.
Oh, this is already bad.
Oh, I already lost a lot.
What?
Where did this guy come from?
Oh.
Oh no, this mission's already over here.
This one I actually have to go straight.
No!
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's
fine, it's fine.
They're on me, they're all...
He's focused on me, he's focused on me.
Oh my god, my game almost got my game card.
there what the fuck I just think what was that it looked
like my game was a bug crash there
oh come on I have no more bullets
we're at site C extracting comrade father don't mind he's
the last one oh where I was this way it's this way oh fuck I
missed another call
God damn it.
Can you do the poster again?
I missed another one.
Alright.
I hate this mission.
I think this mission is the worst one.
Honestly.
This mission fucking sucks.
All right, I'll eat my noodles while I wait for the buzzer.
We got out, guys.
We got to wait for the buzzer.
I swear, please don't make me go downstairs.
Please, I'm doing an escort mission.
Don't make me go downstairs.
I already have a lot of things to worry about.
Guys, he's not doing the buzzer again.
No!
Did I miss my quick time event?
Don't do this to me.
Oh, I don't do this.
Oh, I did.
I'll be right back.
I need to stand in a better spot.
I'm excited.
They've already taken two of the prisoners.
They're escort AC means business unit.
All them to personnel.
Keep that chopper down.
HQ watch the Rubiconian secret.
to die with them far better than risking a leak oh i didn't
even realize i got back i'm back okay now the worst part
father julyan has been extracted oh i hope my ship lives oh
you you don't know what you're saying girl there'll be
nothing left but dying embers This I think this is the worst
mission out of I just it's just oh my god this ship like I
feel like they they wasted your budget on something is
definitely not they definitely did not use it up for the
money to protect a goddamn ship The budget has definitely
been wasted on the wrong thing for sure
Oh don't do this don't do this Where's the me?
Where's the last one?
There you go.
Where's the big guy?
Where is he?
AP at 50%.
Alright, there you go.
Here you go, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
It's me and you.
There we go.
What's that guy?
What's that?
I was like, who's that guy doing?
I don't remember that ship.
All right.
Thank God.
Thank fucking God.
Yeah.
Oh, the worst mission out of the way.
Thank God.
The worst fucking mission, guys.
The shopper has exited the combat zone.
Mission accomplished.
a symbol of resolve but mark my words there will be nothing
left but dying embers i don't know what this crazy man
saying the worst mission so far no no okay my drink is here
all right
one new message let
me thank you again raven rescued our all right don't worry
get up and stuff now finally got everything i needed got my
drink ibis and a guide to us all but you get my lava juice i
love lava he carries a heavier burden than any of us oh and
um a personal note before you go thanks for saving so he i
owe you one
Oh, I love guava juice so good.
All right.
Next mission.
Now it's smooth sailing for a bit.
Now it's back to speedrun time.
Skipper, skipper.
Have I done this before?
Yeah, I have.
What stranger?
A mandatory inspection or a job from another person?
Oh shit, sorry for Skippa, Skippa!
No!
I skipped the skip the...
I got down!
He gives me so... Dad gives me so many missions!
Commence mission.
Eliminate the PCA's mandatory inspection squads.
I'm grateful for your support, Raven.
can back out okay sorry dad
all right that's good i'm gonna eat my food while i repeat
the briefing he gives me so many jobs got a job for you six
two one request from an independent mercenary call sign kate
check the briefing greetings raven My name is Kate Markson.
I have a special request to ask of you.
It concerns the elimination of PCA mandatory inspection
squads dispatched to BAUS Arsenal number two.
Aside from subject guard, the PCA has also sent an LC squad
to put further pressure on BAUS.
BAUS, however, intends to disrupt the inspection with a raid
by independent mercenaries.
Not me?
He hired all these other independent mercenaries Not me?
I'll disrupt their rearguard squad outside Then rendezvous
with you
That concludes the briefing Looking forward to working
together Okay She's cute She sounds cute What stranger A
mandatory inspection Or a job from another mercenary
Whatever happens, handle it.
Just like you always do.
I'm good at my job.
Main system.
Activating combat mode.
Commence mission.
Eliminate the PCA's mandatory inspection squad.
Okay, no, it's the right way.
I'm grateful for your support, Raven.
Of course.
Oh.
Code 1.5.
Where did it come from?
Eliminate it.
Well, I just walked through the front.
Honestly, I just walked through the front door.
So it's crazy that you're like, where did she come from?
I'm like, there was a door.
What do you mean?
I just walked through that one entrance.
Okay.
unknown i'm raven you're gonna know my name soon
how dare you not know who i am i'm gonna make a name for
myself right now we're being pushed back shut that ac down
this inspection is a priority all right oh there's this one
guy the look the peekaboo on me you thought you could just
hide there if i don't see him he don't see me i looked into
this kate she's not even registered in the arena oh be ready
for company if her plan to ambush the rear guard goes south
oh shit she's not registered we're like seeing She's
illegal!
This position's under attack too.
Presently exchanging fire.
Right on schedule.
Looks like Kate's on the move.
What do I do now?
Oh wait, what?
Where's that?
I'm looking up.
Oh, he's right there.
That hit?
Yeah, it is.
Don't worry.
Get a green card.
Green card marriage.
Me and Kate.
I second wife.
The inspection squad inside the arsenal has been wiped out.
It looks like we beat Kate.
Raven, I finished mopping up, but I have something to
report.
What is a new way?
The PCA has made an unexpected move.
Let's rendezvous for now.
Huh?
Where?
You heard the lady.
Oh, here.
Alright.
I don't think I've had enough stamina to make you pass this
gate.
Oh, I had just enough.
Alright.
It's not cheating.
I haven't met her in my third life yet.
Raven, the wall climber, I presume.
Oh my gosh, she even gave me a cute nickname, guys.
We're so in.
As much as I'd love to stop in Chad.
Yeah?
I'm afraid we're rather pressed for time.
Yeah.
Wait a minute.
Why is there...
This is a three...
Wait a minute.
There's a three...
There's a lot of people here.
Wait, is this a one?
Okay, to be fair, it is a 2v1.
Or is it?
Like it's a little, yo.
They're all so fucking fast.
Oh, I'm hitting the armor.
I don't know where the fuck oh it's right here.
Oh!
Did I hit it?
Did I hit it guys?
God he's so armored though.
He really is.
Now that like...
Oh my god!
I hit everything but my sensor!
Okay, okay, okay.
you to pick up the slack here cave you want to be my new
wife my second wife
where is his fucking head okay please
my i can't see him there we go okay is that armored or
There you go.
Thank you.
Of course.
Oh, yeah.
Maybe a second date?
Do you know for a second date, girl?
Here's my number.
It's a commie, maybe.
This is a good restaurant.
I'm going to order from here.
this place again.
I really like the Takoyaki and the Udon.
Oh, hey, Carla.
I see you've got a new augmented human.
What happened to 617, the rest?
Their jobs.
They did what it took to get us here.
So how's the newcomer doing?
Relatively stable, it seems.
But we've run into Someone shady.
Someone you want me to look into.
Um, Kate.
Independent mercenary goes by Kate.
Imagine that.
That's actually pretty hardcore, you know?
Everyone has these, like, badass code names and everything.
She's just Kate.
Beware of Kate.
Two new messages.
Kate the mercenary.
Raven, thanks for the help with the mission.
We'll meet again.
Oh, shit.
It's cool.
It looks like a pen tip, too.
Got a job for you, 621.
This request doesn't come from the corpse or the liberation
front.
You'll see when you check the briefing.
Alright, guys.
I don't know why it's a new dialogue and what is it now.
Now it's unknown territory.
Oh, wait, this is watchboard.
I've done this, right?
right personal request from a friend of mine it concerns a
certain facility a watchpoint it's the one where i have to
be sneaky i'm not gonna be sneaky you'll be going in
undercover of darkness be ready for anything
i swear to god raven comes up here don't tell me this is
where i meet Raven.
She's going to surprise me for a third time here.
It's go time, 621.
Well, Joki, you said don't tell you.
Not even the PCA would anticipate a solo independent
mercenary.
Get in there and get to work.
Surely Raven's not going to come up here.
That'd be pretty cool.
crazy we have no evidence if anyone sees you handle it be
pretty silly that happened how it's just one ac who are they
with we can look into that later engaging
oh whoops as an accident let me reset this real quick Ghosts
emanating, requesting backup.
I can't get through to HQ.
The cavalry isn't coming.
That's fucking right because I killed them all.
Alright, I should kill him.
Last one.
Alright, nice.
Oh, so easy.
Oh, there's...
Never mind, this is the last one.
See if I can...
That hit?
There you go.
Confirmed.
Enemy squad destroyed.
Move on to the next area.
Oh my god.
Fucking colors I've got.
Oh, whoops.
All right.
Here we go.
Where did that come from?
All right.
Here we go.
I don't want to kill the big missile first, yeah.
Whoops.
Never mind.
It's going to hit me first, I guess.
It's going to hit me again?
That bitch.
Oh, I did not see that one.
I forgot about that, okay.
No, not that one.
Whatever.
There's going to be a recharge resupply anyway.
Don't worry.
There's a resupply here.
That's the watchpoint's control center.
mind there is no resupply here oops hit my mouse against my
udon
attacking a watchpoint you're incorrigible handler walter oh
welcome back and then after i kill him raven's gonna come up
or even the middle of the fight nope where is she Oh,
where's Raven?
Oh, oh, oh.
Behind me?
What?
Okay, that's cheating.
Oh, my God.
Don't think twice six to a point.
Kill him before he kills you.
Oh my god, where is he?
Where are you?
It doesn't even matter.
I'm dead anyway.
It doesn't even...
And they're always there!
Oh my, just kill me.
Just end it.
It's for your own good.
And...
Oh my god, why?
That's fine.
It's fine.
Oh my god, it won't even...
Maybe I'll see them here before I go.
Maybe they're setting up.
You know, maybe they decide to set up, you know?
You.
6-1.
Stop.
Behind you.
Hello, Walter.
I'll be coming for you next.
Oh, yeah, I got one of those.
First, the dog.
See, one, two, four, nine.
Sula.
He's an independent horse in the area who survived first-gen
augmentation.
Like, I'm running out of bed.
I got a...
Oh, my God!
He's just jumping!
It must be controlling them too.
Don't think twice.
Kill him before he kills you.
Two repair kits remaining.
Oh, that better hit him.
I don't care.
Was it 618 I killed last?
This guy.
I don't care.
All right.
it's a 1v1 oh what you live okay now it's a 1v1 oh
my god he's using the bridge against me he's using he's
using a bridge against me bridge
bridge tech right now oh
you fucker you actual fucker
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
It's over.
It's over At the break.
He's using the terrain.
Confirmed.
Enemy AC destroyed.
It's not a whip if he sidesteps it, guys.
Better trade the control center and destroy the target.
If he fucking does a sidestep.
Alright, now I get resupply.
Here we go.
All right, down I go again.
Round five.
Destroy the device in the center.
Oh, waste time, waste time.
Yeah!
Waste time, waste time.
Good job, 621.
We're done here.
Head back to base.
Wait.
No.
621 get out of there my wife is there
but the voice voice she's calling for me who are you wife an
older type of augmented human fourth generation Why?
Have we made contact?
I am Air, a Rubiconian.
I can hear it all over and over again.
Before your consciousness is forever scattered in the coral
flow.
Yay!
That's one way
Oh my back at it again I don't know if I'm gonna
I don't know, I feel like I got really lucky last time.
Put your hands in the art and thank you for the super chat,
thank you.
Thank you.
I got really lucky last time because I got to punch the
ship.
You'll have to break its pulse armor to inflict meaningful
damage.
Okay,
I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it, okay, I got it
again.
There you go.
I got it, I punched it!
AP at 50%.
Okay.
Two repair kits remaining.
Oh my god, there you go.
Five still.
Okay, never mind.
Still easy.
Still.
Oh, wait.
Does he have second life?
No, I don't think he's coming back with that.
No.
Yeah, I was like, no, I don't think he's, I don't think that
man's coming back to life.
That's right.
Easy.
GG.
No re.
Raven you need rest of course my beautiful wife oh is that
sweet but first a warning the
coral surge you were swept up in that was just a glimpse I
can listen to her voice all day
a premonition of the storm of flame that will burn Rubicon
so
beautiful Aria Look at that What a beautiful sunset That me
and my wife get to look at Jealous
A brainwife ASMR, exactly A localized coral explosion Caused
by the search As a certain directionality It's headed
straight for the central ice field Across the Aaliyan ocean
Like a flock of birds or a school of fish, coral loves
company.
Which means, somewhere in the ice field, there's a huge mass
of coral lying dormant.
It's not new yet.
Do I skip a skipper?
Yeah.
That's a common side effect of all gen augmentation.
It's my wife, boys.
Could also be from getting caught in that coral.
search don't let it bother you raven hello the coral
explosion completely vaporized northwestern bellius's bay
area and even yet compared to the fires of ibis that
explosion was hardly a spark raven i have a favor to ask let
me remain in contact with you until we She moved in again.
Guys.
Yeah.
We're taking a relationship to the next step.
She moved into my head.
How this struggle over the coral ends.
I must.
As a Rubiconian.
Yeah, we met like...
Two hours ago.
Dramatic pixie brain girl.
D-4621.
Entering standard mode.
One new message.
I just don't know what to skip anymore.
Six to one.
I've got some business to attend to.
I need to hawk some intel to the corpse and secure backers.
Okay, can you spend your money?
What do you mean?
I put more money in bacon now so I can get more interest.
Guys?
That's an order.
Okay, guys, let's just...
Well, last time I actually skipped dialogue.
handlers away on business for now.
About that trip to the ice field, we've received a job from
Baylam already.
Let's take a look, shall we?
Okay.
Alright, let's see.
This is old, right?
Skipper, Skipper.
Oh, Zach, because I the same?
Okay, chapter 2 is the same.
Alright.
Everything's skip-a- time.
It's skip-a-skip-a time!
Alright, that's good to know.
I can just speedrun this part.
I can just miss that.
213?
Maybe you should get out of the car.
That'll give you more upgrades.
Okay, maybe.
Maybe chill.
Chill out a little bit.
Maybe.
They wrote these guys first.
All right.
Here we go.
Stop, man.
He's ready to stop.
It's the druggy.
Well, it was the druggy.
Holy shit.
Actual one punch.
Invincible run.
Maybe a little too soon.
I spoke too soon.
Yeah, pimp slapped him.
My...
My hat was simply bigger than your hat.
I played that these were that way.
Where did we go?
What the fuck you can do that?
You can dodge too?
oh god not that i hate this area it's like a little it's a
trapped area right
oh i always can this is where i always get lost i'm pretty
sure
but and then try to get down there
Oh, up.
Oh, got up.
Oh, there we go.
Why is he a trap in this area?
Oh, my God.
These little guys want to fight.
And this is where I almost exploded.
It's not going to happen a second time.
Or was it third time?
I lost count.
all right this is not going to happen the third time i
remembered this time there was no one month there wasn't
like one month of me forgetting about everything on this
area
there we go see look at that
all right Got me the first time.
Shame on me.
There we go.
Yeah, I got the chest already.
Fooled me once.
Shame on you.
Fooled me twice.
Also pre-fucked up.
I'm on a wheelchair.
Alright, Carla time.
Shall we, Raven?
yes we shall my beautiful wife in fair I actually did not I
didn't look up to fair I just know there was explosions and
you're like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa she's got to be on
top whoops I mean that works too I guess
that's five oh I did not do that good man keep shooting
there you go I keep walking into that there's no way she'll
walk into that third time there's no way it.
Surely not.
But there we go.
Don't keep me.
I can't control my drifts.
Before even M, I was inside of it.
Whoa, jealous.
Don't keep me believes.
Oh, don't you
Nice.
That was a fast.
That was a speed run right there.
No way she would walk into it a fourth time.
Alright, apparently all this is old so I can skip a skipper.
Skip a skipper.
Hey, tourist.
It's me.
Garla.
I had to work some of my magic to track you.
Skipper!
Alright, nice.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'll be back.
Ah, my favorite little tourist.
About my promise to take you up top.
I need a little help cleaning up first.
See, a certain someone smashed up all my defense hardware.
I've got rival dozers muscling in it's the junker coyotes we
never did get on always sniffing around just waiting for a
chance to bite making a mess is one thing but the going
after our development data too we need to swap the hacking
drones they sent before they make off with all my secrets
yeah it's pretty low of them but at least give them credit
for knowing where the value is anyway did I mention that
this is all your fault you can make up for it by keeping my
secrets safe
I'm back Forward, Duck, Jay, and Papa, Solid, Alan, and
many.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, here we go.
We didn't skip a skip of this, but now we skip a skip of.
There we go.
All right.
When do the new mission starts, guys?
Let's get rolling, Taurus.
Is this no snowman time?
Lame.
through again.
Which one is this?
No, it's not.
This is different.
Oh, it's this one.
Ah, I hate this one.
This one sucks.
I'll just scan for these.
Okay.
Turn me up down here.
I was gonna say there has to be one down here.
Oh, what the fuck?
Whoops.
Not really.
You know what?
It doesn't really matter anyway.
I got the second one anyway already.
If it were me, I'd raid us from orbit and just yank our
servers.
I don't like this one.
I like this mission.
Very annoying, honestly.
What the fuck's that?
I'm walling!
Alright.
One over here.
What the fuck?
Take no damage.
I just find this one boring on a mission.
Alright, get out of here.
I'm gonna punch you out of here.
You'd have to try to mess it up now.
Two repair kits remaining.
Oh, what?
I didn't see...
Oh, I didn't press...
I just pressed C because I tried to spam V.
Oh, now I'm lost.
Which mission does Doki like?
Nira, they listen to Risha, I think...
That's a good question.
I think the one where I kill the child.
Honestly.
Security breach has reached 50%.
I don't know!
If you can't spot the targets, try using your sand.
Carl, I'm trying!
Oh, fuck.
I'm lost.
I'm lost!
I don't know how to get to the other side!
How do I get to that one over here?
Oh, I don't know.
Oh, my God, so he is right here.
Oh, my God.
I hate this area.
I hate this.
I hate this mission.
I'm just lost but this is where I leave
Maybe that'll teach him to behave I'm just lost in that area
The radar are there more of them?
All right, and this is where I fight that one bitch where I
just did dodge and everything
Huh You're the freelancer from the damn raid
All right And here I thought I'd just make some extra
scratch Well, I guess I can settle the score at the same
time All right All right, wait, someone knocked on my door
Wait, give me a sec, guys Oh my god, I'm so busy today
All right, sorry Busy day, I'm so popular
It was free.
I got the Muhammad Ali boxing trunks.
Yeah, that's what it was.
I need to bring it inside.
But I'll bring it inside after stream.
I fucking hate you.
All right.
You're gonna die.
Brutal, thank you for the 10 gifts and shit.
2020 gifts and shit.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Oh my god, I can't see anything.
Oh, just shoot him.
Hey, I'm hoping, I'm hoping.
Oh, I'll just wait.
I'll just watch.
Oh, shit.
I wanted to watch.
I'll just watch here.
I'll watch from here.
Oh my god.
Why me?
Hold this bitch.
No, fuck you actually.
We're gonna- I'm just gonna die.
I'm dying.
I'm dying here.
I'm also- I'm gonna die anyway, so it doesn't matter.
I'll just die.
Wait, I live.
Oh shit, I guess I'll die to the little guys then.
Wait, I live?
Oh, this is awkward.
I didn't expect to live here.
Wait, oh wait, he's alive, okay.
Oh, this is awkward.
Oh, I'm definitely not living now.
I'm...
Now we can finally be alone.
Your next freelancer.
No!
I thought he died.
I got your league, freelancer.
I'm very lucky for them.
What do you get the chips?
Thank you.
Oh my god.
I thought he died.
I thought I killed him.
I didn't know he lived.
I see the coyotes got some help too.
You know, I really owe you money.
All right, there you go.
You got lucky at the dam and I'm gonna use those.
Is that it?
Oh, nice.
Ah!
Oh, I mean, share.
I meant to deal with these guys now, though.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
Oh my god, I can't see anything.
There's too many things in front of me.
Oh, I can't.
kill these guys i didn't kill him
okay that's bad there you go last one oh we're good no more
enemies detected all right now that was a speed run i'm
gonna have to look into this
Nice.
I'll do what I can to decrypt them.
Thank you, wife.
I appreciate that.
Thank you, my wife.
All right.
Next mission.
I wonder if I can complete it today.
How long do you think it'll take?
How much do I have, technically?
those encrypted columns they identified you as an impediment
to the release project but what is the release project
yes well i'm gonna take though five okay two out okay i'll
take the two out two hours well if it takes two hours
shouldn't be that bad this will be our third sortie together
raven i'm quite enjoying the routine
she enjoys spending time with me oh my gosh oh my gosh
everybody can do spending time with me here we go tourist
i'll lead the way just as promised but after this you owe me
one
okay all right let's go whoops back this thing go straight
to the top of the grid
Oh wow.
I'm hopeful that it will take me two hours.
The PCA satellite see everything.
A few of the stupider dozers took it as a challenge.
Went out to prove themselves.
You can guess what happened.
I finished all the arena missions.
There's been any new ones.
We've arrived at the top.
Sending you new margarita.
Oh shit, is it?
Oh, is it?
Oh, fuck, okay.
That's fine.
It's okay.
Can't get me when I'm under here.
Now I don't know where to go.
Okay, it must be here.
That must be the PCA security system.
All right, you can't see me.
But I just...
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, stop, stop,
stop, stop, stop!
Be careful, Raven.
Woo!
It's okay.
Hey, that's so powerful.
Oh, I'm so juicy.
Yeah.
If it's so powerful, why can't it hit me?
Oh, that's a little too close.
That's a little, a little too close.
Ha ha ha!
Damn right.
I was always here.
Alright, it's time to fight her.
Alright.
Might as well.
Oh, what the fuck?
Let's get rid of these guys That's everybody.
Yeah, that's what I like to see.
Let's get the cargo launcher ready
Okay, time to fight her I'll give you supply real quick We
supply free the toy
Alright Now to fight the big mama See if I remember how to
fight her, though.
Gotta loop the looper.
Oh, shit.
My job missed the...
Oh!
Gotta loop the loop.
The loop, the loop strat!
Woo!
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
I keep looped the looping.
Oh, no, now she flies.
It's taking off.
Okay.
Watch out.
Oh, shit.
This could be some good R&D data.
Can't wait to get back to the workshop.
Oh, get back in the air.
It's one hit.
Okay, it's two.
It's two hits!
It's five hits!
There you go!
Seven hits!
It's seven hits!
Easy.
Eventually, if I hit R, it'll, it'll become one hit soon.
That was quite the show, Taurus.
How about we get back on track?
There you go.
What?
Oh shit, this way?
Haha!
Brace yourself.
Guys, he was...
He was eight hits, he was eight hits, guys!
Eight hits!
By the way, Taurus.
Your Walters helped, right?
There's me.
Skipper, skipper!
All right, new messages.
One new message.
Well, I'm going to skip it.
I'm going to ghost it.
All right.
When do I hit chapter three?
When does chapter three start again?
I don't remember.
All these chapters.
Oh, wait, I have new arenas.
When did I have this guy?
When did they add this?
Oh, it must be when I skipped.
Wait, I skipped 80 things.
Oh, now?
Oh, now I'm in chapter 3.
Steel, haze, ortoose.
It clearly isn't a mass-produced AC.
Why don't we see how it performs?
Rusty's new mech?
Oh, he has the cat ears in his back.
This mech has cat ears.
Reggie, you're so cute.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, he died.
That's okay, right?
I can't heal you, can't heal.
Oh, shit.
Wait, wait a minute, but you have a shield now.
Wait a minute.
Oh, now he's actually one hit.
Pet the dog.
No, I did all my half this data.
Maybe it's because it's being made right now, you know?
Yeah.
My husband.
He's pretty special, all right?
And he's gonna live, too.
Alright, nice.
Oh my god, he's leaking.
She's leaking the data.
Where's the leak?
Oh, I'm fighting all mine, aren't I?
I'm fighting all mine.
What is the primary factor?
That's why she keeps rewinding me.
I already see it.
Wow, is that foreshadowing?
Hmm.
No.
Is this New or old?
New dialogue or old?
It's a request from one of the Balaam companies.
It's like, it's Roger, isn't it?
Attention, gun 13 Raven.
This job comes from our subsidiary Dafa.
New or old?
The operation will take place in the centralized field.
We're shadowing.
It's literally the place in which.
We want you to stage an attack on the Archibus Survey Camp
located there.
After digging into the ice field, Archibus launched survey
drones to gather data.
All right.
Kippa skipper.
What's this?
Attack the sea.
So, oh my gosh, is this...
Is this the invisible guys?
621.
Are you still hearing things?
I'm not hearing things.
I'm hearing my wife.
God.
Get it right.
It's my wife.
Activating combat mode.
My wife is not a thing.
Commence mission.
Extract the data from the birthed survey drones and get out.
It's the ship.
Oh, it's this one.
OK.
Yeah, I remember this.
This one's like a little annoying, but.
OK.
Huh?
An intruder?
Shoot him just as I can.
Taking Baylon's money, no doubt.
Intercept!
Hey, hey, hey.
It pays good, alright?
How much do you guys get paid, huh?
Yeah, my one job is 10 years of your salary.
Like the one we passed through during our journey here.
Jealous.
We're just jealous of what they can't have.
All right, downloading?
All right, lore that we don't care about?
That's fucking guys out of here.
Just for fun.
Oh, that's cute.
They gave a...
Paperweight as a guard.
Alright, done!
Jump done!
What the fuck?
This guy?
Alright.
I mean, if you say so, I can shut him down.
There we go.
Job done!
Aw, you're lucky.
Oh.
I don't know, but maybe not as lucky as I as I think they
are Job done Looks like you ruffled some feathers taking
their drones back to HQ
Find where what's this way
Oh, they're so unaware, you know what I'm feeling so
generous right now I'll let them live Not you though
Self-defense They shot at me first We all saw it
Alright Oh, look at this tiny guy Goodbye
Alright, we supply Oh, we have the route memorized Hey Oh
shit, it's the giant ship.
It's the giant ship level.
Oh man, it's got to get out of here.
Alright.
Oh shit, they're boom!
I even knew it was coming.
I...
The worst part is that I knew it was going to show up.
And I still got hit.
That's not Subject Guard.
But they sent in an enforcement squad.
I knew all along.
And it still got me.
621.
That's an LC.
The PCA's rank and file.
And a big step up from Subject Guard and T's.
oh my god i can't see i can't see one i can't see my biggest
weakness i can't see my biggest weakness being blind
god i hate these guys so much though these guys are so
annoying
there's all right I'm not seeing her biggest weakness.
They let me fly towards it.
Oh, they do let me fly towards it.
If only they let me fly towards it as it lets me fly towards
it.
I got my wizard ropes there and I can get Merry Berthmas,
please?
Of course, Zonderman.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Zonderman.
Yeah, happy birthday.
Happy Berthmas.
It looks like the coast is clear.
Yay!
The closure area is SG's jurisdiction.
Skipper Skipper!
At least these missions are super fast.
It's just a lot.
It's just a sneaky little idea there.
One new message.
I've seen both sides have been- All right, Skipper Skipper.
Raven.
I've- it's not just- Fuck it.
I'm a veteran This is nothing to me Whoa All right Are any
of these new?
I can't tell I've done so many I don't know anymore Are any
of these new guys?
I skipped a port dialogue Oh my god Oh I thought she said
the same thing the last one is new okay do you think I'm
doing run two or run three because this is run three okay
but it's a four point harder which was easier okay I can't
skip anymore all right I thought I was replaying the whole
thing again hey buddy this job comes from Schneider of the
Archibus group here's the rundown they want you to attack
the Yorgon refueling base a PCA foothold on Rubicon or if
one is hard but it's a must okay a target is the energy
refinery plant deep inside take that out and well it ought
to slow you and what is it anymore until recently jorgon was
one of balum's coral survey bases guys how many remission
how many more content do i have left you'll also find a
number of fuel storage tanks that i've marked as pay targets
i want you to be a walking advertisement for opportunity
skipper
I'm worried the last area is gonna be really hard to get
through it I'm worried trends gonna take me lots of attempts
but I'm worried about the most
oh my god even realize it's been five hours could not skip
after mission cause okay that's good all right what the fuck
I was gonna say how do you live past that.
Code 1-5.
Contact with AC, give unknown affiliation.
Suspect corporate hire.
Single AC.
Terminate immediately.
So I'm just gonna run past you guys.
You guys don't matter.
This is where I kill the cops, right?
Yeah, this is the POPO mission.
End game!
End game.
To my...
RCMP officer listening right now.
I was gonna say FBI but I was like I'm not American must be
after the plant contain the situation terminated that's
right like an independent mercenary that's me where's the
vanguard handle it well I'm running I'm speedrunning this
mission.
Guys, I have 20 more missions left.
Oh, I fucking destroyed somebody's lunchbox.
Oh my god.
Easy resupply.
Actual speedrun.
I felt like I was, I went, I was just there for like five
seconds and I already got my resupply.
I should kill some of these people though.
Just because, or is going to be very annoying when the cops
come in.
For sure.
To get rid of these.
So don't have to worry about these guys bothering me when
the cops are here.
Alright.
Alright, I'm ready.
Send in the police!
Our work here is done.
6-2.
Raven, I'm picking up something in the stratosphere.
Send in the popos!
All right, here we go.
I've identified PCA SP.
Special forces.
All right.
Nice.
Get combos!
Where did you go?
Oh my god!
He was very bad at me killing his partner.
He was three days off of retirement.
Well now, he can retire in hell.
There you go.
That's right.
I mean, dying is considered retirement.
You think about it.
I want to
inspire other mercenaries to work for Archibus.
Yay!
Okay, I have to listen to the after-call briefings now.
Because those are new.
Nice.
Yay!
One new message.
Archibus Group Mercenary Liaison?
V8 Pater here.
Impressive work on the refueling basis.
Thank you!
message addressed to you if I may I knew you could do it but
that is all we at the archivist group expect much from you
all right I'll do one more mission I'll do like the one more
of the side missions and then and then we'll we'll call it
here and save the next one for next week as I have to be
longer and i'm getting tired i'm i'm getting tired now i
have a feeling it's not gonna be two hours i'm like i don't
know if you guys accounted for joki time because i'm not 20
missions and i was like that's not two hours guys especially
like an hour of that is listening to them giving me briefing
you know oh it's the bottomy man swinburn has dispatched
surveillance squads to monitor Yeah, I was gonna say, I feel
like one hour of that, it's just me listening to the
briefings.
Okay, I know briefings is like...
Old.
In order to ambush and eliminate the target undetected.
Alright, it bothered me, man.
I spared him before.
I think- I- well, this is the third time, so I guess I can
spare him and then kill- and take his money and then kill
him.
Activating combat mode the last time I spared him and then I
like and I let him run away I decide I guess I can like
spare him and shoot him I guess I guess
So stupid Wait what How do you see me God that's
embarrassing
Wow.
How do you live?
Okay, the only bad thing about the not the songbird is that
there's no collab.
How do you see this that thing?
That's the only bad thing.
Because the songbird can do collab and stuff, which is nice.
Okay, I gotta go this way.
Alright, I gotta make sure I don't insta-kill him.
Alright, I gotta make sure I'll give him a chance to live.
God, I would love to shoot you down right now.
I...
Oh, you're so lucky.
I can actually just squish you like a little bat.
Put you up to this.
But clearly you need to be disciplined.
Oh, no.
Dude, you don't want me to use my full power.
You don't...
I'll let you heal one more time You think you really don't
want me to use my power bunker right now.
You're so lucky
Yeah, which means I hold the purse strings Every single
transaction goes through me Let me go.
Okay Yeah, one repair kit remaining
You're quick on the other You're you come Who taught you
that?
I taught Walter
Not even a second.
No, Walter got that from me.
One new message.
You have our gratitude for locating Swinburne.
Yeah, I was a Doki Brita original.
I was worried that the enemy might have won you over.
But it seems we can trust you after all.
Glad to be on the same side.
Alright, we're gonna call here, everyone.
I'm getting tired now.
Tomorrow we have the Sloppy Sisters collab.
We mint Lamo and Snuffy and we have a special announcement.
It's going to be around the beginning of the stream that
we're going to announce it.
Because we were thinking about announcing it when we get to
Top of Peak.
But Lamo was like, I don't know when that's happening.
So we should do it at the beginning of the stream.
And I was like, you know what?
Fair point.
This is, you know, like, to celebrate, we're like, yay, we
made it!
We ended up in the end, and I was like, I don't know.
I don't know if that's happened anytime soon.
Good thing you got your jam is on, Russell.
Thank you for it.
I'm thinking, I'm thinking, thank you.
Anyway, thank you for hanging out with me today, guys.
Like, not tomorrow, sorry.
Next playthrough of Armor Core will be our final Armor Core
part for true ending.
I got what a journey I just the longest series we've had No,
what am I kidding?
It's Dynasty Warriors This is the second longest series
we've done Anyway, guys As always, everybody, stay hydrated,
posture Get up and move around to get that blood flowing And
if you stay up for me, head to bed Cause you deserve it I'll
see you guys next time, everybody Bye, guys Bye